meet electronically this is the public
hearing on bills referred to the
committee
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public uh to
observe and listen to contact lastly to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaries during this
meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporary english listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar into the electronic calendar on
the general core website
this the notice for this meeting notice
complies with house rules in rsa 91-8
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
two seven one three six
zero zero i'll say that again
two seven one three six zero zero or
email
hcs
at l e g dot
state
dot nh dot u s
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
brad greenland he's the committee
researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by a roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call of attendance when each member
states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting which is required under the
right to know law
i'm going to ask the clerk
susan uh representative dilumet to uh
call a roll call
uh chairman
yes i'm in the room uh actually in the
committee room with our member uh 11 10
republican members
no democrats
in the house
clerk here
here
that's of course
that's a chorus of course thank you
skipper
yeah
perfect here
really yep great exactly
here and nobody's in the room with me
uh
israel
piedra
cousin
[Music]
no longer in our committee
so
just for your awareness i am taking
janet wahl's place in the committee
and this is representative manny espitia
and
um i'm here by myself
would you please spell that m-m-a-i-n-a
uh
manny m-a-n-n-y
um espitia e-s-p-i
and no one is in the room with me
present and nobody is in the room with
me
hey marie
sorry
casey marie lawton
uh president and uh no one is in the
room with me
present and no one is here in the room
with me
um excuse me nobody caught my name i'm
substituting for somebody but i'm not
sure who i'm substituting for this is
representative catherine harvey
catherine you're substituting for willis
griffin thank you
um
i'm here i'm in my home i'm in my office
but my husband is in the house someplace
i thought manny just this
teeter was uh familiar with willis
griffith
no i'm i'm here for janet wall
oh okay i got it
what's okay
so am i all set
what was who substituting for willis
griffin
i i believe i am my name is
representative catherine
c a t h r y
n harvey
i'm actually looking up on my email
right now to see okay catherine we've
got you thank you
yes i just got the email from the office
yesterday
thank you very much
thank you um what i'm gonna do we're
gonna first of all before we get started
here i want to please um
have the uh representative
in the pledge
representative bel disarro uh matt
wilhelm was not called
oh i'm sorry
pardon me i'm sorry
forgive my wife
i obviously missed that whole
line of people
for some reason i did not get a list or
not like we normally do on the committee
that breaks it down into different so
i'm going off of a sheet that i pulled
off of a committee that has it all
scattered with my my chicken scratch on
the list
who my favorite is like representative
massa miller
all right so matthew wilhelm
uh president nobody's here in the room
with me
sorry matthew please forgive me no
problem thank you
this is new to everybody don't deal with
us here um
you know
we'll make this happen one way or
another
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice
i keep that
and play and those that made the
ultimate sacrifice
thank you
hearing on hb 112.
i'm sorry
okay if you hear any uh see some of my
members that get up you know and uh like
representative loomis had heard her back
so she has to stand every so often you
know like myself with uh disabled
veteran but anyways
well well you know that move on okay
the first um on the i want to you see
here i'm going to go off a sheet here
that was given to me for the remote
testify
uh is magnifoguted uh ready to testify
maggie
okay can we uh
well thank you everyone
make sure your phones are on you i have
a computer that it is on
your voice
thank you so much mr chairman members of
the committee my name is maggie fogerty
i'm the director of the new hampshire
program for the american friends service
committee a quaker founded human rights
organization
we also host the new hampshire immigrant
rights network
the we co-lead with a faith denomination
the new hampshire immigrant visitation
program visiting immigrants
in ice custody at the stratford county
jail in dover
and we facilitate the seacoast
interfaith sanctuary coalition which
provides
supportive services for people coming
out of detention as well as their
families and i'm here this morning to
urge your support of hb 112
which would study the devastating impact
of deportations on new hampshire
families
this bill would be an important
opportunity to bring into the light
the terrible toll
that this
federal policy takes on new hampshire
families we have
many
mixed status families in new hampshire
so families that include u.s citizens
u.s born children but also at least
someone who has been unable to
achieve a secure immigration status
given uh
what a
bureaucratic chaos is our existing
system
so we have seen the
the absolute terror that a family lives
with when they fear losing a loved one
and the grief that they live with when
that loved one is deported
we've seen the grinding stress
on a now single parent family or
older children
who need to
figure out how they're going to pay the
rent or get enough food to eat
and that economic insecurity and that
grief takes a terrible toll
on the mental and physical health
of those family members and those who
care about them including
children in the schools
we hear from guidance counselors that
children are
are suffering terribly either at the
prospect of losing a parent
or once that happens
we have stood with family members
outside of the federal building in
manchester as a a member of that family
needs to go in and check in with ice
and i will never forget standing with a
woman holding the hand of her toddler
and a new baby in a stroller as she
learned that her husband wouldn't be
coming back down from that appointment
that in fact he was going into detention
so watching her trauma
has made a lasting impression on me
we hear from school guidance counselors
and school nurses
about the impact on school success and
children's behavior
we hear from health workers about
all of the health impacts of stress
and even suicidal uh ideation among
young people and people left to to hold
the
the family together or to try to so we
should want to know
the terrible cost of these
horrible federal policies that that have
an impact on our state and municipal
coffers
uh as well as other kinds of impacts so
i ask for your favorable consideration
of this important study thank you i'm
happy to answer any questions you might
have
mac do any members have any questions
uh representative matthew william
thank you thank you mr chair uh i
actually have a point of order question
just curious if uh the prime sponsor of
this bill will have the opportunity to
uh to introduce it oh you know something
hey
matthew you were right and i apologize i
went right into the hearing and i opened
it up and didn't even introduce the bill
so we called that in the morning for a
temporary setback waiting for a solution
and you came up with a solution thank
you
but are you the uh people
uh representing flying knight are you on
see i can't bring her up but i just
stopped
do we want to finish this part and can't
ask questions to the current person
who's testifying or do we want to so i
want to introduce the bill you want to
okay
i apologize that's my own uh
for the while since we've done this here
and uh
as a chairman i've never said that i was
perfect did i all right thank you
thank you welcome to the committee can
you introduce your bill i apologize
thank you for uh backing up for that i
appreciate it
um yes i i'd like to introduce
um
hb112 uh this is a very important bill
i've ex um i've gotten many
concerned citizens
reaching out about
where their tax money is going to
and i know that my fellow
colleagues across the aisle can really
appreciate that concern and the
transparency to know
if we are
hemorrhaging money on a bad process
i think it would be irresponsible of us
to
not know
facts that affect our constituents and
how much they pay out of their paychecks
so with that
um i don't want to take up too much time
since we already back channeled
but that's the intent of this bill to
gather data to see um if
we are
malpracticing as leaders and wasting our
taxpayers money thank you very much
um
thank you
representative i've got
okay thank you uh representative thank
you for your testimony i got a quick
question for you there and this bill has
come to us before
um the us constitution here uh says it's
the federal government's responsibility
each city in town knows how much
taxpayer dollars especially in
manchester they're paying on
immigration uh it's a federal
responsibility why would a state why
would we put a study committee in place
when there really is not a damn thing
they can do
so you're saying rather than gather this
data and know how much
we're wasting
because it's not our responsibility
we should just let the federal
government handle it is that what i'm is
that correct
no that's not what i'm saying i'm asking
you is the federal government
responsibility we already know all the
data we get it all you got to do is call
manchester how much money you're
spending in education uh you have i
already know they have 28 different
speaking teachers uh we've done this
before uh
rochester me that data chairman i'd
really appreciate that
per
immigrant community and per immigrant
child in our public school system how
much money we as municipal taxpayers
have to pay to make sure that they're
not left behind if you have that i would
love to have it if that's what you're
saying that you you've had that
information given to you before
the reason i had it was because before
the bill came in the last time i called
a few places
and uh i don't want to debate over it
i'm just letting you know this bill came
before us before
and did you call these places to even
check to see if they had the numbers
uh yes i did we don't have that
in this state which is why it's it's
really scary that we refuse to even try
and gather that data and that's what
this bill is designed to do so thank you
for your interest in that i am also
greatly concerned
okay thank you are there any questions
representative schulte
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative
for your testimony i just had a brief
question do you know if our federal
government
studied this issue
and they don't have you approached our
federal intelligence saying that this
and you know if our federal government
already studies
um i think there was multiple questions
and i had a hard time hearing you
frankly i'm not sure if you're close
enough to a mic but thank you i'll do my
best
for what i understand again it's a
similar question to what my colleague
asked me of why
i try and gather this data because it's
not our responsibility and i sincerely
disagree i think as
local leaders it is our responsibility
to know how much money our local people
are spending on an issue and if that can
help the federal government
um
make different actions and in different
policies and reform then that is our
responsibility as leaders we actually
do need to work together with the
federal government and um i don't mind
us taking the lead i think it's our
responsibility to do so
let me yeah let me speak louder because
that wasn't what my question was
thank you for giving me answers that
my question was
has the federal government study this
and is it studying it and if not have
you approached anyone on our federal
delegation to introduce such legislation
considering that this responsibility
falls within the scope of our federal
government they're
specifically in the commerce clause of
our constitution um any kind of
international commerce any kind of
immigration and anything regarding
deportation falls within federal scope
so have you approached our federal
delegation about this and does our
federal government already do research
like this that we can use as a state
i'm so grateful for that question
actually if you go to
my facebook page that's my first pinned
um
public segment i was interviewed by wmur
for calling on our federal delegation to
do more on this specific issue and that
we don't have enough data and i am
frankly concerned that um it's falling
on deaf ears again why i call my
colleagues to make this our
responsibility thank you for your
question
thank you i'm going to try to move this
right along here because it's put so
much time i represent martha thank you
mr chair and thank you representative uh
for being here for introducing the spoke
uh i want to ask you as i look at the
bill it specifically refers to
primary earners
that's in the legislation so my question
is if a family member is not a primary
honor
the way i read this they would be
treated differently in
perhaps would be more deportable than a
primary earner could you address that
that distinction that bill seems to make
yes thank you i'm sorry for the
misunderstanding
this is basically an after effect what
happens to our communities and for the
legal immigrants that are here and
if they
necessarily let's say um
a primary earner is deported
and this family is now needs to apply
for food stamps
section 8 housing
any other
medical needs
the onus is on
our town's people and our city people
and um
i don't think that we're we're doing
ourselves justice by burying our heads
in the sand refusing to know how much
money our own people are paying out of
pocket because
we just sent somebody that was working
at a small business that couldn't afford
to pay maybe minimum wage and then a
landlord now loses
his tenant and doesn't have rent we have
to step in and take care of these
families and i think we need to gather
that data
thank you representative all right thank
you
uh representative
thank you mr chairman um and thank you
representative klein knight for
introducing this bill um
so in regards to you know i think this
bill was introduced in 20 in 2019 i
think we had uh or 2020 sorry but i
think we had a pandemic that has
drastically it changed you know the
situation from what it was last time was
introduced to now have you seen impacts
on the pandemic on on these families um
who you're trying to
study yeah
not only were these families in rough
shape before and it was
off of non-profits and other community
members and just
some great people to continue to make
sure that these families were just
getting by
but now with the pandemic we're seeing
an increase in homelessness
and other
severe health issues that are
on top of everything else causing damage
to
our local communities thank you for that
question
okay
are there any other questions
without that i want to thank you very
much representative
thank you so much for your time and uh
listening to this bill
real quick i want to go back out of
respect for uh maggie uh does anyone
have any questions for the first uh
president
um
thank you thank you honorable chairman
and um thank you ms for garthy um for
your testimony i
do have a follow-up question for you i
wanted to know
what is the impact on children of having
both a parent and a primary breadwinner
deported
does trauma like that impact school
performance or have long-term impacts on
a child's
development question to the previous
person
i was thank you very much and i
appreciate the question the answer is we
see devastating impacts this is true
this is a traumatic experience that
affects a child's development for the
rest of their lives it negatively
impacts their school performance we hear
this from school nurses school guidance
counselors uh and from
community health centers
it's it's one of the most
heart-wrenching aspects of this entire
thing is the lifelong burden on
on children
thank you for asking thank you uh
representative
thanks mr chairman um and thank you uh
uh miss for mrs vogerde um my question
is so we have
in in places where there are a large
number of undocumented immigrants we
also have a house like most of those
places i mean and we can speak for the
whole state at large we have a housing
crisis so can you talk to me when when
we lose a member the primary earner how
does that affect you know the housing
crisis that we already have and can you
talk a little can you tell me a little
bit about how that's been affected
well sure thank you for that question
when when a family experiences eviction
which uh thankfully we've had a you know
a short-term moratorium on vic an
eviction but in regular life when people
lose a primary wage earner and aren't
able to pay their rent they uh they can
be evicted once an eviction is on
someone's record it becomes even harder
to ever find another willing landlord to
rent to that family and in a housing
market that
virtually has a zero you know
effectively a zero percent vacancy rate
then the the uh
the impacts on this family are long term
and it's pretty impossible to recover
uh employment and other benefits when
someone doesn't have even a secure place
to live all right thank you um
representative
welcome
olgawitz thank you mr chairman and uh
thank you miss fogerty i'm aware of your
work and have watched you from afar from
here in keene
and i'm wondering about the costs
do we have state data on the costs for
children then
who lose their dads for example
in terms of the iep costs the individual
education plans i know it costs
thousands of dollars every time
we have a kid who's identified through
the iep process
i've only seen as a psychologist and
keen have just seen you know anecdotal
cases
where you know a hundred thousand
dollars then boom for keen
have you seen this and is there data
on this
i imagine there is data but it hasn't
been aggregated into a state level
narrative which is the so thank you for
asking that this is the importance of
representative klein knight's bill um to
some previous questions about whether
the this economic impact has been
quantified uh there are reports and
somebody giving testimony after me will
talk about uh an article from the
journal on migration and american
security about the poverty impacts of
deportation on households but we have
these
data
elements and the stories
in very local places in school districts
in municipal welfare offices and state
human service offices but it hasn't been
woven together into a coherent story and
that's that's what this bill could do
for us
thank you
for the members there that are on the
computer there which is confusing to me
if i'm not looking at the screen
uh can you please put your hand up i
mean check on the number the end up i'll
check on ray's hand
so that way their uh representative
will let me know who's on there because
i might not see it but you end up here
at that point
representative
and one other last thing before i go
there the next bill under uh hb 117 for
those that are waiting on
we're running a little bit later
can you hear me
yes
thank you mr chairman and thank you miss
bogarty for your testimony today so
based on what you just said you said
that there is data that affected
globally so could theoretically a
non-profit integrate this data and
create a database to be able to implore
um think tanks and our local officials
to take action on these specifications
we have some concerns especially
regarding um possible social welfare
programs for people a lot of primary
areas
uh thank you for the question i think
there are several non-profits
who would be important partners in this
effort
but certainly the
the authority or the weight of a
legislative study would would invite
agencies to take this request seriously
and to participate as fully as they can
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your
anastasia so
so theoretically that a non-profit could
aggregate all this data together
and be able to compile it in a way
that's helpful to
informing public engineers
yes i think that there's an important
role for non-profits
alongside the important role of
legislators gathering information to
inform smart public policy
thank you i don't see any other hands uh
we're gonna go to the next week uh
thank you
um
will be
good morning
good morning what is yours
okay thank you
okay so
good morning
my name is bruno sorrys and i am an
immigration advocate at catholic
charities new hampshire
and we support this bill and urge you to
do the same
the great impact of immigrants being
deported from our communities
is far beyond one can imagine
in terms of economical impact there are
approximately
fifteen thousand undocumented immigrants
in new hampshire
according to a study
conducted by the new americans economy
in 2018
the study shows that undocumented
immigrants have a spending power
of 518
million dollars
and contrary to what many believe
they have paid
67 million dollars in state and federal
taxes in that same year
another research published on the
journal on migration and human security
is stated that three-quarters of
undocumented immigrants in the united
states are self-employed and are
generally the bread winner for the
household
the research has shown that
if these undocumented immigrants
are deported from the mixed household uh
families
the medium household income
would drop from an average of 41 000
dollars
to 19 000
which is about 47 percent decrease
furthermore
if these u.s us-born children
were left in the united states
the estimated cost to raise them
would be
billion dollars
and gentlemen i have shared with you
today the economical benefits that
immigrants have
to our economy
but the moral question
that remains unrested
is what if
it was your family
thank you
i want to thank you for your information
actually you just opened my eyes up i
just haven't been researching
thank you are there any questions from
the committee
so uh mr chair if you don't mind may i
answer some uh questions that were asked
previously to my colleague
um
miss
i i appreciate that if you can send that
to us in an email because we have to
move on uh and i want to answer the
question maybe throw it out
put it out there when the question comes
your way yeah i just have one brief
question i'm according to the study that
you cited
um of the three-quarters of undocumented
immigrants uh who are breadwinners how
many do you know send money income
varying from outside of the u.s to their
families does that number report it
because i know there's a number of
immigrants who
work in the us radiating for years or
even just seasonally send a lot of their
income
over back to the countries of origin
where they're from whether they have a
visa whether they're undocumented or etc
does it say within that study how many
of these folks who are impossibly
deported how much of their income with
actually staying in the united states
so um so it is hard to so these numbers
is just like the census it's uh only
um
it's only based on you know the data
that you know that is able to be
captured
uh but generally speaking uh the
majority of uh immigrants documented or
undocumented
uh they also helped to support their
families abroad uh you know like despite
the fact uh you know having um you know
immigration status or not
um
i would say you know like over 90
of
immigrants that live in the united
states they still send money uh you know
like abroad despite their uh lawful
i mean despite their immigration status
uh and the reason being is because to
most immigrants family is a core
value
of our culture
and you know like helping our families
that you know struggle abroad is
something that is essential um you know
to keep our families uh together even
though uh physically
keep your answers apart
because we're really dragging this on
and i don't want to reschedule this this
hearing if i don't have that i'm going
to try to complete it
but
thank you
more
in just another note i sent uh the the
link
uh to my testimony along with uh some of
their supporting documentation so you're
more than welcome to
uh to take a look at it as well
if my answer doesn't satisfy your
question
uh
thank you mr chair um
so just real quick i
i think nice to see you bruno hope
you're doing well uh
small businesses this is a state that
has a lot of small businesses i know
traditionally immigrants typically have
a
big impact on small businesses can you
tell me what expect like what the impact
has been here when you know with
deportations and um and small businesses
yeah so so uh absolutely
um so in uh talking about you know like
immigrants uh you know like in general
um you know like so immigrants in new
hampshire you know like according to
what they study uh by the new americans
economy uh they have showed that uh
you know these immigrants they have
generated uh
little over 20 000 jobs
uh
in in in the state in the state of new
hampshire alone
so pretty much um
in the economical impact uh it is
certainly definitely something important
that it is money that is uh you know
that keeps the cash flow in our state uh
you know like moving
um and especially
that
you know like the research also shows
that three-quarters of undocumented
immigrants are
uh you know like self-employed shows
that you know like immigrants contribute
a great deal to our state economy
survival
all right thank you are there any other
questions uh there's someone
no
okay um thank you very much here uh
rudolph from speaking
okay and the next one is um yolanda
eureka
if you can keep it down to three minutes
well is it all a hundred
and the reason why i'm going downtown
i'm looking for yolando eureka i'm
switching back from my list here because
i didn't realize it said he was coming
are you there
yeah i am here this is
can you hear me
yes we can hear you
yes thank you thank you mr chairman
thank you members of the committee
my name is alejandro ruti i live in
hudson i live in new hampshire for
20 plus years i was a health and safety
officer with american red cross i'm a
retired physician
but the fact that i i am
bilingual
and my connection with the red cross uh
many families approach to me
for counseling and then i know uh what
is the impact of
when
the the red winner of the of the house
or the home uh is is deported
um there is already i don't want to be
repetitive about the things have already
been said
but um
there is
the psychological impact and have the
children and the family is enormous
and unfortunately these families live
afraid of
of the system and sometimes they are not
going uh to to get um to help get help
and counseling and so the impact that
these families have is enormous
um
stress produced because maybe they need
to leave the home they the house they
live in
maybe they need to go to live with
another
with another family and then share many
many people very small spaces that that
um living spaces that live deal lead to
stress
many uh teenagers need to take the role
of taking care of the younger children
and
and that is jeopardize
jeopardize their the school that
jeopardize the social life of these
children that is needed to uh to have a
sense of belonging and even if they are
an american children
born here
they are not able to properly integrate
and that is leave a lot of psychological
dysfunction
we know i am a retired physician i came
here to united states working on
research
and then i know what is the effect of
stress
long-term stress on people there is
there is a factor of
of the diabetes
even insulin dependent diabetes
there is two factors also there is the
the change on on the food uh habits
because
many people to in order to be able to
feed and is not suffer hunger they go to
junk food that is that is cheaper more
affordable and that is a
but is not nutritious
and and that is a that is that is not
good because especially when someone is
developing
the chances to become obese and develop
diabetes is very high and develop high
blood pressure on early ages
that are risk factors for very serious
and devastating diseases
now i want to talk a little bit about
the var i don't trust the data that we
have and the reason is because many
people that are going through this
for example could be maybe both parents
are undocumented immigrants they don't
want to look for help on the official
official
on government
sources because they are worried about
their
here and i didn't realize once again
you're with what uh a organization here
and you're reading from the script okay
no i am not reading for any script
okay does anyone have any questions for
alexandra
without no questions thank you alexandra
you're welcome
the next one uh yolando i'm going to try
this again now please listen to the name
i'm happy okay
herrera you know she's saying she's
speaking for herself i'm trying to get
regular
you know residents speaking not
lobbyists are you saying yolanda
[Music]
hello
can you hear me
yes okay awesome
thank you for letting me speak today my
name is yolanda huerta
and i'm in full support of this bill
um
i'm a first generation citizen most
recently
a first generation college grad
and primarily
a primary
earner in my family
and if there's something i learned from
my mother and stepfather is that we're
hard workers there's a guiding principle
in our community that if you have papers
you have no excuses or in spanish it
says
you have to get ahead in life right um
while i was in college working multiple
low-paying jobs and the little and what
little money i made was going straight
to my stepdad's visa process my mother's
utilities
and my biological father's fines from
having to park and stay in his car as he
is and has been homeless
now with the pandemic
um
i didn't even realize how good i had it
when i struggled to send money during
those college years um
the pandemic isn't just making the
prospect of supporting someone through
the virus impossible
um i really don't know what i would do
um but the fines coming in from over
policing our brown bodies particularly
when my family members are self-employed
and are not categorized as essential
workers
in a system where we find just about any
way to survive such as my father and
stepfather making money by working as
mechanics
skills they learned when they were
ranchers when they were out back in
mexico
and my mom taking care of kids or
selling clothes at markets or driving
individuals
um
for a small pay um
all of that
isn't really a part of this essential
workers um kind of
like liberty of
connecting with people
at the moment like in supermarkets so
it's not under the same
um situation so it makes me really
nervous day to day i'm thinking that
they're going out and doing these things
to survive but also putting themselves
in danger um
and also putting themselves in danger
not only
um
on the prospect of the um
getting getting and contracting the
virus
with very little support um possible but
also um
the possibility of like being pulled
over my mom's driving and
i don't know what that means
really um
and
yeah so
that's my kind of um perspective on
things
um i would love to see this bill um come
forward and
and start studying what the effects of
um
[Music]
what this all means really
all right well thank you
do we have any questions
uh representative espida
thanks mr chair um
so as somebody who is directly affected
by
um
you know
by like you know our tough immigration
process can you just tell me a little
bit about um
like what the effects like you know what
would you be able to do if you didn't
have to worry about paying your families
like bills basically
i mean i'm trying to save up for grad
school like i'm trying to work for
myself
like i'm i went to college thinking um
that was the way out but with the
with loans being a whole thing
um i got scholarships too but they don't
tell you that you need to take out loans
for
x y and z like and even though they're
like not super heavy loans
um
it still bears a burden on me and i
still like am trying to pay those off
before i go off to my next thing um and
so it's really like holding me back
while i see everyone else
getting to go to grad school getting to
go and do their next thing like i'm here
understanding what to do
um to support my family through this
whole situation
okay thank you are there any other
questions
seeing that there's no other questions
um can we bring up uh castillo
steve
[Music]
and uh please uh can you state where you
caught where you're from also for the
secretary for the clerk
can you hear me now
yes we can hear you can you please state
you let us know where you're from
i live in manchester
uh
and
i have worked as an advocate for
immigrants for over 30 years here in the
state of new hampshire
if i may what what group are you with
then have you
i am part of every single a pro
immigration group in the state pretty
much
okay thank you if you keep your
testimony between under three minutes
without being with it
sure i'll try not to repeat myself i've
been a member of the latino community in
new hampshire for over 30 years and i
worked for many years at the latino
community at the latino center
so
i have seen
so the devastation that in that
immigration uh the and deportation
brings to the families and i'm gonna
tell you a little story about a family
that came really close to my heart two
years ago when their father was deported
he's been here he was here for over 30
years with not any type of criminal
problem or anything so the two younger
children were 9 and 11 at the time
and his wife uh he they have a 19 year
old daughter also
the two younger kids are totally
devastated right now
they
are in in psychological care the little
girl that was nine she has tried to
commit suicide three times already the
boy has turned into anger he's angry at
everybody the mother he's acting out in
school he doesn't want to connect now uh
in the internet the mom has to go to
work so she has to leave the the kids
with the oldest daughter when she can
the other daughter was forced to
to put a cut down her classes or college
classes and work because now she feels
that obligated to help support the
household
and
the mom has lupus and the stress has
brought the lupus on
before the father was the main
breadwinner of the house and he was able
to provide for the family
in every single aspect now they are
being they have been able i mean they
have been obligated to use the food and
rental assistance uh and you know this
is just
one single
case
uh
and it's not
the people that are deported that are
suffering you know we we lose the when
we lose the main breadwinner we lose the
the spending power of the whole family
we lost the taxes that these people
bring to our state we we we spent a lot
of money educating them and giving them
counseling and giving them stuff that
before they did not need because they
were able to afford it on their own
so
when they live in overcrowded like
alejandro said my son when i adopted a
mexican boy a few years ago like 10
years ago there were 17 people living in
a two-bedroom apartment because they as
as the brothers were deported the wives
would move in with their children into
one apartment because they could no
longer afford to rent on their own so it
is in our best interest as a community
to
see what how much money we we spend on
them so i support this bill 100
thank you
thank you are there any questions
forever
brady there's no questions i want to
thank you very much brad are you on uh
right now brad
oh yes i am hey brad on my mic here when
the red uh when the red is does that
mean it's on or off
on if um
that means it's off if you're asking
about your tile that's popping up on the
screen
yeah okay so i have to make sure when i
press the button that the red light goes
out then
so because you're in the room the mic
should pick you up and um you don't have
to undo or else there'll be um some like
reverberation throughout the room
i think i think you should um i think
the red means it's muted so if there's a
button okay i think we should test it
right now
can you test because i have some people
are going on and on when we're trying to
slow it down to get it under three
minutes here and i'm just wondering if
they're hearing me if there's a problem
brad can you hear me off my mic
yes i can i think claire
okay so the red light has to be on then
okay all right thank you because i'm not
hearing me when i when they go way past
three minutes that's why okay thank you
uh the next one is um
daniel hernandez please uh tell us where
you're from and keep it to three under
three minutes
there it is
okay
yeah slow can you hear me very well
okay uh thank you honorable uh chairman
and thank you to the committee my name
is samuel hernandez and
i'm here with coalfire an organization
led um
student-led
at dartmouth college and
i'd like to i'm here to support this
bill
so
i would like to bring up that on though
uh for mixed families although this um
undocumented status may only be a
symptom of
uh primary breadwinners um
that kind of identification is really
diffused through the family um that are
from um
kids and primarily like their children
can also be associated with that symptom
so they might be although u.s citizens
but they're less likely to um associate
uh
with uh
with with help from from school until it
becomes unmanageable
so i believe that um studying the
effects and especially now uh with more
um tumultuous times
that
understanding the economic um
this uh the economic um impacts that are
gonna be felt in the community for a
very long time that are gonna be um
maybe underfunded and it won't be clear
how long um this
this recovery
might um actually take um because
uh schools will have to spend more uh
individualized time with more struggling
students and um
these students are more prone to be from
families that are undocumented and have
lost these primary uh breadwinners
so i'm here to support that bill i'm
trying to keep it under three minutes
but i think that it's extremely
important
and i think that it's in the best
interest of the state
try and learn um what the economic
impacts of that um those consequences
are
thank you samuel appreciate your
testimony any questions for samuel
uh representative dilemmas
thank you mr chair
thank you uh mr hernandez
and this is
probably a pretty touching question but
and probably you're going to think i'm
not
what is there now when the primary
correct winner you're talking about
people who are illegal immigrants right
these people are are undocumented
because they're here illegally so when
they are
brought
out
and
they have to go back
somewhere else deported
can their families go with them i mean
can their families just you know when
they let's say they go back to bogota
can their families just go to bogota and
be with them there where they can earn
money
um i'm just gonna repeat the question
because i was kind of uh i'm gonna
repeat it back to you so uh i i'm
understanding correctly you're you're
asking if um if families can basically
get deported as well
with their primary
breadwinners
because as an extension you're just
saying like
they also
could leave or
otherwise be deported as well like
self-deporting um to answer that
question i think that it's very
difficult to imagine um
for any
any students
to
i'm sorry
the question came out wrong um yeah
we've got to make it quick if we can
yeah i'm sorry i'm mr
i said you know can't they just go i
mean so they don't have to be deported
i'm just saying
that
that they actually should probably
uh can they go you know
get a ticket play ticket and go with
their family and with their husbands or
primary friend winners and go to
wherever the person that's being
deported goes they are not being
reported they can
voluntarily leave correct
i think that anyone can buy a ticket and
leave anywhere um i don't think that's a
problem but i think that if you're
talking about um uh taking opportunities
away from u.s citizens that um that
these children are u.s citizens then i
think that that's
um kind of alarming that
the state might want to even uh consider
that because i think that as
as uh citizens i think that they also
have a responsibility to these um to
these kids
so um i don't think that that's a
reasonable choice no
thank you mr hernandez for your powerful
testimony my my question is are families
forced to rely on social welfare
programs after immigrant breadwinners
are deported
so
it is uh under my impression that they
are so um
some of our work here are basically um
is based around kind of organ organizing
and and promoting and speaking at
different like immigration advocacy and
reform um during like in college here
and also surrounding areas of new
hampshire and vermont
and we've had
like many opportunities to
meet these individuals more personally
before the pandemic and and actually get
to hear the story and
even before the pandemic um
these individuals were having a very
difficult time um so
i i can't believe how um
how this is gonna be um even a
a situation that might be able to be
dealt individually within this family um
just within this like tumultuous time
because they don't have the support um
that um other other families might have
okay thank you uh representative are
there any other hands up but we all said
we're gonna move on to the next one
because if i have to use this i'll
recess until about 5 30.
so that way there we
go no other there's one other
okay because i'm determined to finish
these nine bills today if it's going to
be dragged out then we're going to be
here late then uh okay
what was the name again i'm sorry
maria perez
uh thank you for for the opportunity mr
sheriff
i headed up question for bruno and i i
had my hand up since bruno
spoke um and i want to ask bruno what
the impact is because um
he's he was saying that a lot of these
immigrants they provide employment
to a lot of citizens or our state
there some of these immigrants they have
a small businesses where
uh they uh provide
employment so i just wonder
what their
the impact is when these immigrants they
get
deported
and um u.s citizens lose their jobs
okay i i want to thank you for i want to
ask you a question to bruno but if
that's for the uh state representatives
here the ones to be asked the question
uh you would be on here to
uh give your testimony on where you
support the bill or not support the bill
and i'm supporting the bill sir and
that's why i'm speaking and
i'm supporting the bill because we need
to study this
we
as an immigrant not us proud to be a
citizen
i believe that we need to we need to do
a study we need to like really study how
much money the state is losing when
these people get deported
they provide
jobs to a lot of citizens of this
country
and not only that
but
what is the impact when these farm these
family members get deported how much
money they're causing to the state
when we have to provide education
medical care
and then all the other needs for the
family members who the u.s citizens
and i was like really disappointed when
i heard
why we don't send their family members
with the person who got supported
because they're u.s citizens
and they have the right to education and
they have they have the right to stay
here
and
and have better life
and um yeah
and that's why i'm here i'm so important
yeah i didn't realize that you are a
state rep i recommend when you use zoom
and you add in rep next to your name so
we would key in on that there um
if you're not with my committee you can
testify but you don't ask questions uh
you know to people that are testifying
but i want to thank you for your
testimony i mean are there any questions
we didn't have there's no question oh
i'm sorry representative
i see we're going to go to sleep at nine
o'clock tonight but go ahead
thank you mr chair uh and thank you
maria for uh coming to testify my
question is is it true that some of the
kids
of these primary bread earners who are
being deported is it true that some of
these kids might only be american
citizens and not citizens of the
countries that they would be deported to
it is true
some of these kids
that were born here
and at the
u.s citizen only and that the only thing
they know is
english and they the only thing they
know is
their own country the us
and then for them to be deported to
another country
that be not going to be really harmful
because um it's like
taking away the rights
thank you representative i i see no more
questions i'm going to call up um
asthma
al honey and can you tell us where
you're from and also um please give it
uh
under three minutes thank you
yeah can you hear me
yes we can hear you yeah so my name is
asma el hee and i'm the movement
politics director for rights and
democracy in new hampshire and i'm
speaking in favor of hb112
um i am an immigrant and i am also a
citizen but i was not always a citizen
of this country um i hope we do care
enough to know how deportation affects
constituents um yours and our community
members so the role of public policy is
vital in gathering data it shows we care
about this issue even if we do not care
about it it should at least we should at
least know how it's affecting our state
it's just the responsible thing to do so
one of the things i need you to know is
that most of the undocumented community
members
enter the united states legally
and oftentimes visas get expired and
people might not get paperwork or know
how to fill out paperwork right i
remember as a child our landlord would
call my home and tell me to tell my
mother that they were going to report us
for complaining about for example trying
to fix our house right
um and as a child i was very confused
but i knew that if police were called on
our family it would not wind up well
because we knew we should never never
call the police and that just means that
we were afraid police would call
immigration customs enforcement now i
know this committee is about what
happens to citizens of families when
their breadwinner gets deported but i
want to expand this to include all
families not just citizens because
people all people should matter here
children never ask for the conditions
they find themselves in so we have to
have sympathy towards all children not
just those that are citizens i
personally know of a family where a
child lives in a mixed
family their father was deported two
years ago their father was arrested at a
gas station when the employees call the
police on him and people of color are
oftentimes racially profiled right and
so police came and they handed him to
ice immigration customs enforcement he
was from brazil but he was born in
australia they deported him to australia
a country he knows nothing about he just
was simply born there right and he had
to figure out a way to get to brazil
because he can no longer come to the
united states this father has left two
children
um
which they have not seen their father
for two years the mother
who was employed when her husband lived
in the united states they did they both
were working but now that her husband's
no longer there she's taken a huge
financial blow right um and i did not
even ask the mother you know what is
this doing to her children because i
didn't need to we can all imagine what
it could feel like to have a loved one
torn from our lives right new hampshire
can't turn a blind eye on the fact that
immigrants not only contribute to our
communities as other speakers have
already mentioned but they're integral
to our communities and our state and
when we deport families that's one more
person that does not contribute to our
communities that's one less spender
that's one less worker that's one less
friend that's one less community member
and one society less that is what it has
the potential to be right so this study
committee is vital it's important for an
erased community whose impact is great
but oftentimes never known
can you please close it up there well we
have to move on thank you all right i am
finished thank you
thank you um are there any questions
uh representative espida
keep it quick um just a question thank
you mr chair um question for asthma just
uh would you believe that we
that not all the undocumented immigrants
live in nashua air manchester
yes absolutely i live in lebanon and the
story i told you is actually from
lebanon so yes that is true we have
immigrants all across our state who are
contributing um community members
okay thank you um
there's no more questions i want to move
on to thank you for your testimony i
want to move on to nancy uh pierpoint
have fun
please tell them can you hear me
can you please tell us where you're from
and please keep it under three minutes
and do not read from my testimonial uh
thank you
i'm nancy pierpont i attend madbury
united church of christ and i live in
madbury
we share our church building with
maranatha indonesian united church of
christ
i signed to
testify as myself
because i i didn't have a powwow with my
church before getting on this call
and i also volunteered to chair
for the new hampshire conference united
church of christ the immigrant and
refugee support group neither did i have
a powwow with them
before
i
decided to testify today
the
new hampshire conference united church
of christ immigrant and refugee support
group that i chair
provides
a detention
bond and post-detention support uh for
those who are caught up in the in in the
snare of immigration and custom
enforcement
what i would like to do is to tell a
short story i will provide this in
longer detail uh written testimony
because when i saw
uh
it took about six minutes to tell
i decided i should really condense the
story
basically uh i met a man in
immigrant detention a devout catholic
who was um
who had fled a drug gang uh in honduras
he had been given an ultimatum of either
to join join the local drug gang or be
killed
and when he refused
he was shot
when i visited him in detention he
pulled up his shirt and showed me the
the
where the bullet hole had pierced him in
the side
he came to our country to ask for asylum
and was summarily didn't uh thrown in
detention
and um
because our system is so overloaded he
was denied asylum while he was deported
his father was killed assassinated by
the same drug gang and for the reasons
that they were still trying to get at
him
he decided that
[Music]
he needed to come back to this country
looking for safety the second time he
came he did not ask he did not turn
himself in because he knew he would be
just sent back to the danger he he
escaped from
so he crossed the border without
permission and began to make a life for
himself
he met a young woman
who already had a special needs child
and he fell in love with both of them
they got married
they didn't have enough money to
hire legal representation so even though
he was married to a u.s citizen he
that's why i met and met him in
detention
the end of the story is uh that he was
deported and killed
he and his wife had
three children together twins and a and
a little girl
uh the wife was
became homeless because of his detention
she was expected to get uh service uh
homeless services expected her to go on
job interviews
she left the twins with a um
she left the twins with a friend and one
of the twins was beaten blind he will be
legally blind for life
and this is the fallout from our
detention system i will i will give you
um articles about that but i want to
just outline that there are four
children four years and on under who
have no parents no support we have to
school them provide them with trauma
care
and uh
okay
thank you um
are there any questions for miss pierre
park because she's not listening going
on and on and we have to move on and
i've given him any opportunity to close
it up um
seeing if there's no questions um i see
that um
representative um
maria perez already spoke to us and uh
she has her hands up and i want to thank
her but you've already testified and uh
other is there anyone else that um has
any questions uh uh that one that we
don't have that wants to testify that we
didn't get
is there anyone else on there
uh representative you have a question
honorable chairman i wanted to know how
many people have signed in
in support of the bill and how many
people have signed in a post
i'm going to get to that as soon as i
but just before i get ready to close the
hearing thank you mr chairman
is there anything else
okay seeing that there's nobody else on
there um and i like i said i respect my
fellow representative uh that wants to
speak again but we're gonna move on um
and therefore before i close uh on this
bill here
there was uh 64 in support and two
opposed on there
i want to thank you all for coming
forward intensifying i'm going to close
the hearing of the house bill in 2012
and i'm going to open up the hearing on
house bill
1 17 18 117
and i'm going to ask representative john
graham this should be a quick one
since we've all supported this report
and uh representative graham were you on
yeah
and i apologize to my friends
all right thank you mr chairman
um for the record i am representative
john graham
from
bedford which is hillsborough district
7.
i would like to point out as the
chairman just said that this bill is
exactly the same as passed by the house
a year ago
it passed the house was heard in the
senate
was part of an omnibus bill that the
governor vetoed and the veto was
sustained
so we have resubmitted this bill which
deals with
use of force on our national guard
facilities
members of the adjutant general staff
will be testifying after me to talk
about the rationalization
of of our rsa to bring it into line
with both the air force and army
regulations which are not the same
within the dod
it is important that we do this so that
our forces meet in the national guard
are operating under one rule here in the
state
and with that
we will try to get you back on on track
mr chairman i will take a few questions
but i would ask it
any questions about
the difference between the air force and
army regulations or what the
national guard plans
uh be
deferred until they are speaking thank
you
thank you representative of course this
bill was um unanimously um you know uh
14 and nothing on the vote the last time
it came forward the democrats
wholeheartedly supported it so hopefully
this will move forward are there any
questions for representative john graham
okay thank you representative with that
thank you i will get you back on track
okay thanks i'm moving fast um is there
eric uh radburn who opposes the bill
okay you don't see him okay i i will
move on uh we'll hold him in case he
comes around
uh
kevin grady welcome aboard kevin
kevin
kevin grady is with the state veterans
advisory committee which i'm a voting
member on
okay can everybody hear me
okay great thank you
for the record my name is kevin grady
i'm a 21-year resident of new hampshire
i live in hooksett uh today i'm here uh
representing the state veterans advisory
committee which was chartered by rsa
115-8-colon
a colon8 to speak for the veteran
community uh in new hampshire uh there
are 19 members of our organization for
those of you who might be new members to
uh to the house um
and they remember their names are
familiar to you things like the veterans
of foreign wars and the in the
american legion i personally represent
the air force association as i'm a
20-year a 25-year air force veteran um
we did support this bill last time we do
support this bill this time primarily
because what it does is standardize the
way we do things in new hampshire with
the way that the the active duty force
does things and the more that you can do
that particularly in an era where the
the guard and the reserve forces of our
military are interchangeable with active
duty forces in so many different areas
the better that it is and that's all i
wanted to tell you except to sowing a
little pitch for us in that if you're
trying to put together a bill
that has that you think has veteran or
guard or something like that impact we
are a resource that you can use and
we're more than happy to invite you to
one of our meetings to explain what
you're trying to do that's all i wanted
to say mr chair
kevin
are there any questions for mr grady
seeing that there's no questions thank
you very much there and we'll see
hopefully the next meeting again i'll
see you okay whatever
uh well without further delay i want to
bring up uh the
assistant adjutant general warren perry
welcome aboard there laura
can you hear me sir yes i can
hey so good aft uh good morning uh my
name for the record my name is warren
perry i'm the deputy adjutant general
for the new hampshire's department of
military affairs and veterans services
as was stated uh the intent of this bill
is to align the state statutes with
regard to the rules of usage of force
for
uh with the department of defense
department air force department army uh
rules for the use of force this
particularly affects our contract guard
force who are
not state employees but they are
contractors
for the state of new hampshire and it
just allows them to use the same rules
of force that the department offense
folks use at our facilities around the
state there are 17
uh army facilities excuse me facilities
and of course we have the pease air
national guard base
so uh i will take any questions you have
with regard to the bill
uh thank you are there any questions you
uh thank you very much warren appreciate
you coming forward
um jeffrey chain
welcome
well we're waiting for jeffrey there uh
keep in mind there like hp 112 or any of
these other bills coming forward
he's not on
okay i may be uh you know hold the
executive session when we're done or in
between so be prepared for that
okay without uh we'll move along is uh
eric back on yet eric rather
good morning mr chairman
oh okay ltc how are you lieutenant
colonel
good sir uh good morning ladies and
gentlemen of the arnold committee um as
mr perry and the asvax chair indicated
um this bill is to bring in uh bring
our law into alignment with the dod use
of force rules in addition it's it's
really to uh bring it in line with the
original intent of the law um
which um due to no fault of the drafters
uh due to the fact that there is no
longer an army regulation on the rules
for the use of force it relies on what
are called the chairman's
joint rules
this will simply amend that and bring it
into the original drafters and bring the
law into alignment
i stand by for any further questions and
i appreciate the opportunity to uh
testify for this honorable committee
well thank you are there any questions
what signed in on this one here is for
support and one opposed
i want to close the hearing on thank
everyone there and thank you for your
service for those who testify david
veteran uh i want to close on 1817 thank
you
give me one second get organized
john did a great job getting us back on
the track
okay i want to open the hearing up on uh
i 8580 to welcome the sponsor
representative craig
good morning thank you mr chair uh good
morning members of the committee and all
the public who are listening
i introduced
house bill 580
in order to
reinforce
the federal law on deployment of our
national guard
this is not a
question of foreign policy
it is not a commentary on
foreign policy
it is simply a reminder of what the law
is
the law does require that
for the
national guard to be deployed
or called to federal service
pardon me
without the authority of the governor
that it be done so in
to repel an invasion
of the united states or its territories
or to uh uh in a declaration of war or
in a time of war
or that it be done um
to enforce the laws of the united states
and of course
due to the
posse comitatus act
enforcing the laws of the united states
domestically
would require
invoking the uh insurrection act so
we're not at that point
our national guard
i want to thank mr warren perry for the
data that he provided me our national
guard
from new hampshire has been been
deployed overseas
some element or another deployed
somewhere overseas
in hostile zones
continuously since 2001
so there's never been a time that we
have not had national guard deployed
overseas in combat zones
that's continuing on into 2021 now with
our air guard
there is a lot of misunderstanding about
federal supremacy
when it comes to this
i'd like to try to clear that up
somewhat
until 1987
governors could simply refuse
uh to allow their guard to be
placed into federal service
then
with the
uh what's called the marshall amendment
to title 10
uh that was modified so that governors
can no longer withhold their consent
based on their objection to the
place
uh
or mission of training
and that is for training the supreme
court upheld that that governors cannot
withhold consent to activate national
guard for training even if it means
being deployed overseas for training
that is only for training
that does not apply in cases of combat
this is a much simpler issue than most
people
try to make it
the law simply says that
uh
in order to be activated well together
without the governor's consent
that there must be
a declaration of war
an invasion to repel
or to enforce the laws of the united
states
so this does not conflict at all uh
with federal law a matter of fact it
repeats it
and
states that
simply that the governor
will withhold consent absent any of
those uh
justifications uh that should be an
automatic
because
the the governor simply uh shouldn't be
allowing our guard to be deployed
without those uh things which are
what is uh called for in the law in the
first place
uh i
won't take up any more of your time with
explanation but i will entertain
questions from the committee
uh thank you uh for your
introduction here uh representative do
we have any questions for uh
representative craig
okay uh representative welcome
thank you chairman um so i just have a
question a hypothetical question so for
example the vietnam war was as i
understand was not a declared
uh war by congress
so if um we were in a conflict say again
in asia
and uh it was not a declared war
and so by doing this would the governor
then be able to say sorry new hampshire
is not going to participate
or something like the
invasion of afghanistan following on
9 11
would the
with the state with the governor then
say yeah but we're but we're not going
to be able to we're not going to
participate because we don't agree with
that
that action
that would be a uh
issue of policy
my bill does not address
the governor objecting to one particular
action or the other
it is not based on objection to the
place or the nature
of the deployment
it is simply
that the
law
would have to be in votes uh so that
there would be a declaration of war
now whether or not an authorization for
the use of military force or the war
powers act would qualify that is a legal
question for the courts to decide uh the
courts so far have not uh
settled that issue
congress has largely
uh abdicated its power to declare war by
simply
giving the chief executive uh carte
blanche
but
again that's a that's a
a policy question
that would not matter in this case um
under what you propose say another
vietnam or for
the invasion of afghanistan or iraq
uh no there has not been a declaration
of war there's not an
imminent invasion of the united states
and we're not enforcing uh u.s law
if we can keep the you know pretty short
questions
for you there um and if i can just get
you a real quick answer on this here so
we can move on is under the uh court
case that went on
uh the perfect
versus department of defense uh where
the case was argued in front of the
united states supreme court where the
governor of the state could either
withheld consent
of regard to hacking outside the united
states because of any objection location
uh supreme court upheld this law by a
vote of nine to nothing supporting uh
federal government
what say you on that real quick
absolutely the purpose case
that i mentioned during my introduction
governor park pitch of minnesota
objected and withheld his consent
after passing the marshal after passage
of the martial amendment
and he did that based on
both the location which was honduras and
the nature of the training and that's
not allowed under the
marshall act for training and the
supreme court case
repeatedly said training it only
addressed
training that a governor may not
withhold consent uh when guard is
brought into active service for training
because all national guard
training is done under
uh u.s army
and not under the national guard so
naturally
it does allow uh active duty for
training and that training can be
anywhere in the world
which we all know most of it will pay
out freshman freshman on here under
title 30
training but the thing is the governor
right now under title 10
um really had those except for 50 of the
national guard is and i'm gonna have
warren perry on soon to verify
uh i mean my memory has gone in a lot of
this here but
um did anyone talk to you about that on
past historical data here in the state
or throughout the country with title 10
because that dealt with title 32
i'm sorry you were breaking up during a
lot of that yes this only applies to
title 10. it it quotes title 10 exactly
the
the basis of the law is title 10. uh
does not affect any activation for title
32 at all
okay thank you i'd like uh you have a
question yeah
uh representatives thank you thank you
uh chairman of sorrow and thank you for
testifying and particularly question
representative
so my question is in regards to the uh
pepperidge first department of defense
decision uh
by justice stevens
specifically in that case there's a
clause that stevenson
mentions of the uh
of the 1986 montgomery amendment which
explains that withholding a governor was
holding their consent for national
guardian activity outside the country
the site purpose or schedule was fought
with being upheld in that case so
in the case throughout it the justice
uses the training of an example of that
specific circumstance
but he explained that they're upholding
the entire amendment he determined
montgomery and then
four years prior to decision 1980
so my question is twofold
do you think that this was wrongly
decided and that the scope's too broad
with the supreme court decision and do
you have any um
any scholarly evidence or any
constitutional scholars that agreed that
scope of this decision should be limited
well
the decision itself limits it itself to
training
it was only
about training uh
the case was about training uh there was
not a
title 10 activation
at question and the supreme court did
not go beyond the balance of the case
itself so the case was only about a
training mission
representative
thank you uh mr chairman and uh thank
you
representative craig for taking my
questions good to see you outside of our
fish and game meeting um
i just found out that i was subbing
yesterday at 4 so i
have to admit that i didn't have a lot
of time to do any research on these
questions so i might be asking a very
silly question and if i do um please
excuse that
is the national guard ever deployed
overseas for
natural disasters of floods hur
earthquakes whatever and
is would this bill um impact such a
decision
i'm not aware of any uh it's certainly
possible particularly when it comes to
our air national guard
refueling mission
if we hit our flying
supplies or relief efforts somewhere
but uh i don't believe that that would
be affected by it um
certainly not the intent uh but uh
uh if that would uh
that would be uh certainly a brief
activation uh that could fall under
training uh would not necessarily be
a title 10 activation
representative correct that might be a
question for the next speaker there uh
with the adjective
but um
are there any other questions uh
do you have a follow-up representative
hobby question no okay
yes actually i i do and it's not really
a follow-up it's just a reit
reiterating his answer because um this
is new to me
so what you're saying is
even if this bill would pass we would
still have the opportunity if
in some brief instances the national
guard needed to be deployed overseas for
national uh natural disasters that still
would be able to uh take place is that
what is that what your answer was
telling me representative craig
if i may that's really a question that's
in general him just like me a retired
marine
and i would save that for the adjutant
general
okay
thank you i i apologize like you said i
you know this is new to me and i didn't
know until yesterday late that i would
be um on the board so i i do apologize
for questions that maybe aren't either
too simple or not appropriate thank you
that's my question to the next speaker
thank you
all right
kevin i want to i mean representative
craig i want to thank you very much for
coming on i see no more other uh
questions without without further delay
i want to uh ask um warren perry
welcome aboard wine
he'll clarify a lot of this question
good morning again sir uh again it's a
pleasure to be here before the committee
uh can everybody hear me
yes
so the department takes no position on
this bill i submitted some written
testimony late yesterday evening i know
some of the members of the committee has
seen it
our interest here is to ensure that the
committee is aware of any impacts
that this bill's passage may have on
the operation of the new hampshire
national guard both on the army and the
air side
so our biggest concern is it puts at
risk
federal funding
up to the amount of 100 million dollars
a year if passed so if the if the
governor withdraws consent for any
reason for the federalization of the new
hampshire national guard the president
and the federal government have the
authority to withhold funding for the
national guard
uh that's problematic because it
includes wages for all of the 2 800
members of the national guard all the
operational costs to uh to uh to keep it
moving
and the positioning of our major weapon
systems
all of which are owned by the federal
government and
loaned essentially to the new hampshire
national guard those include the
blackhawk helicopter which is uh
instrumental in our search and rescue
efforts in the white mountains the kc-46
uh refueller and the high mars rocket
system which is really a
a weapon system designed for engaging
with and destroying
enemies of the united states
uh
it would also uh impact
the strength of our units right without
funding we can't we can't have units in
in the new hampshire national guard
600 of which are responding right now to
the pandemic
in
uh
essentially under the control of the
government but in a title 32 federal
status right so even though they're
title 32 folks
uh
and they're uh
being
paid by the federal government they're
under the control of the governor
and again about 600 of them are doing
that across the state
right now so
i would encourage you just to review the
written testimony that i provided last
night i know it was late i apologize for
that
working with the lawyers to get this
done i would say that it was a pleasure
to uh to communicate with representative
craig with regard to the history of
deployments for the new hampshire
national guard
but i didn't know what his intent was
when he was collecting this data so we
provided you know in a very transparent
way the number of uh
of deployments we've had and uh the
extreme high operational tempo that the
new hampshire national guard has had
and we're happy to continue to engage
with him to talk to him about the
impacts of this bill
uh
if he so chooses
pending any questions that you might
have uh i'll conclude my testimony uh
thank you um lauren warren can you speak
to uh representative harvey's questions
that she asked the last speaker
so it just depends on how we're
mobilized right so there are two there
are two statuses that that uh that
generally well there are tons of
statuses right that members of the new
hampshire national guard could be in the
two big mobilization or act uh full-time
active duty kind of statuses there are
under the provisions of title 10 which
they are completely federal
and under provisions of title 32 which
there's some question whether or not
they're state or federal and it really
gets to
who's controlling the guard not
necessarily who's paying right so for
example
now when the hurricanes hit puerto rico
we were able to use our
our airplanes from peas and our soldiers
and go down and support the relief
efforts in puerto rico
generally in a title 32 status right but
paid by the federal government so this
the state didn't have to to pony up
money to pay for that
there are some instances where we have
state uh the national guard and state
status and their
excuse me they're generally responding
to state issues right so we've had some
folks at the department of corrections
working we've had folks working with uh
department of employment security those
folks are generally paid for out of
general funds
so if
if there was a disaster and it was
required that the national guard support
that reset uh disaster somewhere in the
world it would probably be
in a title 32 status but it could be in
a title 10 status
and it would
generally uh it could be prohibited by
this by this bill could you know but i'm
not i'm not a lawyer
so i really have to go back and and talk
with the staff judge advocate to get a
real answer about that
but you know i i would think that the
governor would always consent if it was
about human suffering i mean
politics would be a side on that
uh i would say uh that
so hopefully that answers your question
representative harvey i can see you on
the screen shaking your head i hope that
answered your questions a long
long-winded answer i apologize
representative harvey i know you didn't
ask the question but i'll give you an
opportunity if in fact uh did he answer
any questions
uh yes he did thank you so much mr
chairman
all right thank you um
representative moffat has a question uh
yes sir uh thank you question and
hopefully a follow-up uh does the new
hampshire national guard have
uh personnel in an ir individual ready
reserve status whether they're
retirees or not
so the short answer is they're they move
to the i what's called the ing or the
irr so they are generally have separated
and still are serving some part of their
military commitment in the ing or irr
it's not the same as the reserves though
it's a little bit different the inactive
national guard
my follow-up is uh
would this legislation impact uh an
individual as opposed to a unit in other
words if there was a need for somebody
with a medical background or a special a
special background
would this legislation impact the
activation of an individual in your view
so
i think it would the the the legislation
is written such that the governor would
have to consent to any federalization of
any member of the national guard so the
short answer to your question is yes i
could go back and read it again but uh
it doesn't say units it says guard
members
thank you
thank you are there any other questions
uh from mr um representative this year
yes uh thank you mr perry for uh uh for
your testimony and particular questions
thank you mr chairman for recognizing me
i would just want to you could briefly
explain
the um the dual enlistment principle
that's cited by justice stevenson uh
i could i could not explain that i have
not read the stephen's decision so i i
have no no basis to you know without
reviewing the stephen's decision i i
can't comment i'm sorry
warren what that question is your lawyer
that we met before in committee is he
available are you at the
headquarters
he he is he is not available now he's
actually processing people onto title 32
state active duty to respond to the
vaccination effort right now so he's
doing the legal briefs to bring people
on to support the state he uh he sent me
a note at the end of uh it's colonel
chang he sent me a note at the end of
the last testimony saying i gotta go i
gotta get these guys out to give shots
to people i apologize
okay we have a follow up for
representatives yeah i'll ask you them
more simply
um
do guardsmen take two oats and if they
do take too old so which entities do
they take those votes
they take so the guard swears an oath to
support and defend the constitution of
the united states it's a very you know
it's very noteworthy oath against all
enemies foreign and domestic and also to
support the constitution of the state of
new hampshire and its governor and obey
the laws of the governor and the laws of
the state the orders of the governor and
the laws of the state
what is the um of taking these votes
thank you for letting me take the
follow-up and thank you for answering
your questions
what's the consequence of taking these
two worlds what kind of responsibilities
can entail after taking help
well you know i i i don't have the state
oath committed to memory i apologize but
it's pretty simple support support and
defend the constitution of the united
states that's the the federal oath obey
the orders of the president united
states and the order supported over them
uh and so that obligation is when when
ordered by the president or when ordered
by the governor they're obligated to
follow those order
thank you mr perry i think are there any
other questions uh for warren perry
seeing that there's none uh warren thank
you very much here for your
testimony uh with that i'd like to
welcome
kevin grady with the state veterans
advisory committee welcome kevin again
thank you mr chairman
once again just for the record my name
is kevin grady um i'm a 21 year resident
uh of hooksett uh 25 year
air force veteran and today
again i'm representing the state
veterans advisory committee um unlike
the previous bill that we talked about
where we actually were in a meeting and
we had a vote and it was a unanimous
vote for this one because this came on
before we had a chance to it was after
we had before we got the language and
after we had our january meeting we sent
the bill around electronically to the 19
voting members of our uh our committee i
heard back from 15 of the 19 members and
all unanimously opposed the bill
uh and the reasons that they said that
is because primarily since desert storm
we've we've downsized the military to
the point where you'll hear a lot of
people use the total force
concept words which means the guard the
reserve and the active force what it
means is if you were to sit down and
drop all of the missions that our
military has to defend our country and
our interests worldwide you would find
that we have more things to do than we
have people to actually do them so we
rely especially in the air force we rely
on the the national guard
every day if you're flying on an air
force airplane some place across across
the ocean you might have a guard crew
you might have a reserve crew you might
have an active duty crew you might have
a mixed crew you might not know who is
in fact flying this airplane it could be
a peas airplane being flown by active
duty people even though pease is a guard
base and the truth is as as as uh as
cole perry said you know that the the
state of new hampshire didn't pay for
these kc-46s
any more than the state of vermont paid
for the brand new f-35s they have
sitting on their ramp okay we need these
people to do uh the total the total
awards here um and so so basically
what the
the flavor i got from my members is that
this this bill unnecessarily ties the
hands
of uh of the governor or the state or
the of the guard
in in ways that we we really can't
foresee just sitting here uh around a
table or around a zoom screen
the flavor i got from all my members is
we're trying to solve a problem that
does not exist
we're probably we're trying to add
legislation into something that that is
not an issue uh there's there's no unit
and colonel perry can can disagree with
this if you want under as far as i know
there's no unit deployment uh to
overseas um of our guard units as a
group
that isn't coordinated well in advance
with not only the state but the but the
active forces everybody knows it you
might have a onesie or twozy
uh
individual specific skill set that we
need somewhere that doesn't get
coordinated well in advance but all the
rest of the stuff is coordinated well in
advance the governor is on board with
with every decision that's being made
here because he's briefed on everything
that's going on so again our members uh
the 15 of the 15 that i got unanimously
do not support this bill that's all i
have mr chairman thank you for the
opportunity to speak
oh thank you very much kevin appreciate
you always on the ball
uh
questions or anything for uh
representative
i mean for kevin uh without seeing any
on my screen i want to thank you very
much for your testimony is there anyone
else out there that uh we missed that
wanted to testify
representative representative jess
edwards we have him on here
uh are you available are you up
no i'm
i'm i'm here i assume you can hear me
yeah you
okay so
a little bit about my background i
served in a hybrid capacity active duty
and national guard reserve
over the course of 33 years and four
months exactly one third of a century
and
uh with my time in the guard and in the
reserves uh i have a pretty deep
understanding of the role of the guard
in the reserve as part of the integrated
force structure of the united states
military
it was designed that way post-vietnam so
that um
it made it politically more difficult to
go to war because it would require the
public support
of the nation in order to allow guard
and reserve to be called up and deployed
and so there was an understanding at the
very outset uh
of the in the in the 60s and 70s
of needing to diversify what kind of
capability
each of the components guard reserve
active duty you know what what they
would bring to the table knowing that in
order to have a whole set needed for war
you had to bring them all up
and
so uh the the reason
i am a supporter of this bill
is
uh that i think we need to have a
conversation that we have gotten further
and further away
from some key core fundamental
constitutional principles one of which
is that the declaration of war
is the obligation
and duty of the congress and and they've
forfeited that since world war ii
uh and i would like the governor of new
hampshire to have in his quiver
the argument
that
we shall not as the people of new
hampshire deploy our forces in harm's
way
unless the congress has done its job
first to declare war
and um and so so um
so i'm not a peacenik uh i volunteered
uh to
go to afghanistan and leave my family
for a year
because i believed in what we were
trying to do
to convert that into a stable nation
with equal protection under the law
and uh i thought it was a worthwhile
endeavor i did that personally i
volunteered for that but uh but i would
like us to know
that
[Music]
history has shown
that executive power often uses
military adventures
as a political tool to bind their
domestic politics and although we've not
necessarily seen that in our recent
history i i don't know i can't predict
the future and so i would like us to
recognize that the reason the
declaration of war was given to the
congress was to make sure that the
public stayed behind it
and and i would like uh our
governor
to just have another option to say
thanks but no thanks
uh get your act together declare war and
we're all in with you so
so this is the beginning of a
conversation i hope you give due
consideration to uh representative
craig's bill i i think i think there's a
good discussion to be had from it so
so thank you i'll take questions if
there if there happen to be any
well yeah thank you uh while you were
speaking i was trying to find in my u.s
constitution yeah you know it always
pops into you when you're not looking
for something but anyways uh it looks
like brody or representative deshales
wait say that again
it looks like representative details may
have a question but you see him better
than i do okay but i'm the chairman i'm
speaking right now thank you
uh but anyways um i'm i'm asking you
here uh on there's a section under
section two under to come in um
the um commander in chief there
that talks about the seven states that
and he takes control of the militia
um
i'm trying to figure out where you're
coming from on this versus you know what
all the money that the state gets
and the governor is involved so i'm
trying to see where i'm missing
something there you being former
military that's why
so i'm not interested in the money
aspect of this i mean i i know that
people who are charged on a day-to-day
basis
uh have to think about the money but
i don't think uh
the testimony indicated anything about
money being a problem until the governor
invoked a decision to say no
so there's not a money issue unless the
governor perceives such an important
public policy reason that um he or she
chooses not to deploy the force and then
a money issue may arise i believe i
and in any case um when we're talking
about uh
uh
going to war
sending our young to war
uh even some of the old people um
i think there are bigger issues at play
than money i i
you know i i don't i i it creates images
of a mercenary force and i know that's
not the intent um but that that's kind
of where it takes me thinking when we
start talking about money in this
context
okay so
so and a follow-up for me is what you're
saying is don't comply
with the constitution and just go with
uh no sir no sir i'm saying the opposite
i say comply with the constitution
make make congress declare war if we're
going to deploy
soldiers overseas into a hostile fire
zone
that i'm i'm pro-constitution very much
so this bill is very consistent with uh
with constitutional principles i believe
thank you yes sir question for you yeah
uh thank you
thank you mr chairman for recognizing me
and thank you representative for your
own research today and for answering
our questions um so i was just wondering
um do you know
which um part of uh
section two
um
oh do you know what part of article 1
and uh section 8 currently governs
how our
how our national guard for federal armed
forces are who has the role in deploying
those forces
as a constitutional matter
or as a legal matter
i am not an attorney
so i i
don't know the answer to your question i
i think it's a fair question but uh more
appropriate for somebody who's uh
steeped more in the law
thank you
united states supreme court president
and federal law and once
uh
national guard units are called
effective duty is guarded it is um
governed by article 1 section 8 laws 12
of our constitution rather than what uh
hb 580 says which said it will be an
importance but partly
which was called the
militia clause um this would be a direct
challenge if we change what flaws
in this specific section and article
that our governor advised by this would
directly challenge um
years of past precedence years of
federal laws and um even you know it
would be unorthodox compared to how
other states operate and how we regulate
our homeless forces so i'm wondering do
you think this challenge is
something that should be done
even though that it could result in us
losing millions of dollars that we used
to pay these guard units and the people
who are in our national guard and say
new hampshire
so i would love to be sitting in in your
shoes there and having the opportunity
to hear the testimony of a bunch of
different
points of view on this i think it's a
great and vital discussion and i support
it i support the principle that the
governor should be allowed to say no uh
if congress has failed to do its duty to
declare war that that that's that's
where i'm coming from and i i i don't
have much
depth beyond that to offer you i i
apologize for that
uh well thank you
thank you representative edwards
are there any other questions
tonight
seeing none uh thank you
that was a good question you actually
put it i took it the extra step from the
question i was asking representatives
yeah i could tell i thought yeah you're
trying to find the article yet under
section two there because it always
jumps out at you when you're not looking
at it
article one
section right
thank you you definitely did your
homework when i stopped running here
next term uh then i know that the
committee gonna be well in uh good hands
outstanding okay um with that
is there anyone else who wants to
testify
that we're missing out on this on the
list
i don't see any hands on mr james okay
with that i am going to close hb 580
and i'm going to go into opening up
hcr1
and i'm going to welcome representative
abramson to the committee
are you here for committee today um i've
got
five different hearings
right oh okay but what i'm asking are
you sitting on a committee not today
okay we were told that uh the reason why
i'm asking brad are you there
i mean i am i set up in this room you
have to have something man
just show up
can you repeat the question please
yeah brad um max abenson i was told on a
conference call with the speaker that
nobody was going to be coming in to
testify
unless they were here for that day for a
committee in the room
and i have uh representative davidson
here i got tables in the middle but i
have
wires going through
do i have to move around here or to get
him
in an area
um that was my understanding as well if
that's what the speaker was telling you
is um
that
there's not to be anyone else in the
room unless they're
in a committee
right
well he's here now and he's got four
bills
that i have to go through otherwise i
don't want to do another day of these
bills
so
am i allowed to do a table in the middle
with all the wires in him sitting there
um
i can check on that um i'm not
entirely sure um but i will i will check
on that
okay thank you if you can do that real
quick
right
okay
is
[Music]
human services
while we're waiting here when i open up
hcf before i open up htr one uh albright
and dano i don't even know who you are
but anyways you're members of the
committee none of you seen this yet my
name
is in new york i speak in favor anyway
he spelled my name totally wrong
right now he's on his room okay because
he's asking questions why do you think
the founding fathers and claims
there's nothing that you know
unless he's gonna testify
uh we're such fools or idiots to include
so i'm not even going to acknowledge
this guy yet because you know
uh i'd say i think they're such fools or
idiots to include i never said they were
idiots of food
what else do you feel they were wrong on
chairman paul he spelled my name totally
wrong and i don't know if it's to be
disrespectful or what but i made my
first appearance in front of your
committee over six years ago when my son
returned from afghanistan though i did
not serve i committed after listening to
his experience to serve my country
another way in his own as well as my
granddaughter i mean for the record here
for everybody my son is in kuwait right
now
i'm
the marine corps and for the record i
also did 22 years and served in desert
shield desert song and all over the
world so just for mr um
i found the answers i was looking for
was hanging on my wall on my home in
front of me over 35 years
and i called article five of the
constitution jim and baldus on the last
six years you have been against article
five okay i still am
uh back then out of country was 18
trillion in debt now six years later 30
trillion
um for the record i did support the um
uh the balanced budget uh article there
with decision in washington so new
hampshire
75 percent of the country in favor okay
in fact the federal government has run
away under lack of will determination
civic duty
including balthazar will you choose
today
over hope again
i'm gonna i'm gonna choose in the way i
feel is the same way i don't support
article five but thank you for your
questions there and i think you're kind
of rude on uh ratifies with such fools
or idiots to include
sir
yes are we going to be able to uh help
representative al by hearing all four of
his bills rather than
um
you know go to lunch but the thing is
there's no uh the cafeteria is closed
right you know i mean because i i
respect for our members to give them a
lunch break i know all the democrats
that chose not to show up here
you know i mean uh they can just walk
into their refrigerator and eat
but
we republicans all chose to come here
and
do the things that we were elected to i
think personally you know you've done a
wonderful job as a chair
of all of the times i've served with you
and i think it's only fair that maybe
you get on the phone who wants some
pizza for us
treat us okay
i think that there are members uh
representative master miller since he
didn't show you she just had the pizza
delivered for us
i think that there are other members who
have other villages
representative
yeah
you only wish that's a dream of yourself
okay i apologize to the rest of the
committee i'm just trying to find out
the answer if i don't have it for
grabbing a minute or so i'm gonna make
the main decision
i mean seriously this worked out well
the other day
right no i agree multiple uh
but i don't want to go against them
about the sorrow
you're aware the chief of staff is is on
his way over
he will answer you'll be able to answer
your question
all right thank you yeah because i don't
want to go against what the speaker told
me uh that
nobody would be testifying in our
committee and they would be doing it
through the uh zoom
but to my fellow republicans i want to
thank each and every one of you for
coming in and doing the pete this is
what you elected for
and general stock outside is probably
probably all there
because they there was flues they were
called you know all the stuff rewards
they never turned back and said oh no
wait until it's done
you know just like
all the countries i ventured to malaria
viruses and things like that
you know we still fought the laws and
that's what that's probably all for
coming in
well my fourth great grandfather fought
with
stark at bennington so
that statue resonates with
president that's right
so we understand i mean not that i'm
knocking on you i'm just saying it's
just as a military man that's just how i
feel
you know
what paid you know the big bucks to do a
job and
well i'm waiting they said aaron's
coming down i just don't want to go
against the speaker
you know i mean and normally i would
just go ahead and say let's rock but i
was told that
we weren't doing this
except
did you actually um
apply for a key to the opinion i can't
hear you
we'll tell you how to apply here we go
i tell you what
we can't waste no more time here he's
here
uh magnitude is a curveball uh on this
here but you know if i'm not doing it
from home
um but anyways
let's open up here until we see our uh
one
htrs uh
and i want to welcome
representative evanson to testify
just so you know here i have hearing i
like to look at people's faces so this
is gonna be a little tough for me i'm
gonna try to decipher what you're to see
okay but i'm going to go ahead and
introduce the bill i'll try to keep up
thank you members of the committee i'm
representative
i'm introducing
[Music]
uh has been uh submitted by 15 other
state legislators
each of these three issues
general public
there are three patterns
for um
um
my reasoning being for submitting this
is now facing
a thirty trillion dollar grant
uh 84 thousand dollars
debt for every man and child
yeah
james madison originally marketed five
said
congress had the power to submit
amendments
the perfect way to put
james madison right before the
constitution was about to be gratified
he
to turn into a creative writing effort
uh this would not mean
if i have names
it's possible that congress could do a
creative writing force for that this is
not
uh
um
i don't think there's any question
there's
this
some of these items
but the this concern that we heard over
and over again at a
federal expansion of the states
50 legislators
i think that that's um
that's kind of like saying you have an
emergency
and you can call back
you're not going to call 911
around the country
have
uh
congress delegate this one out to the
convention of the states uh i'm also
certain that
um
though there's a slight possibility on
other applications that they might even
aggregate this convention of the states
uh this is definitely not
hcr one i think is a
it's very clear that this is the one
application
did you ever see the question oh is he
done
oh i'm sorry yeah i i couldn't hear you
i mean i apologize so hopefully the rest
of my committee did
you know like i said myself to my
hearing if you notice i always look at
people's face that's why you have to get
mass there so uh but anyways uh are
there any questions
uh yes representative
go ahead
sure um you have to if you can just
speak a little louder
the risk foreign hazard from such a
convention
would you agree with that
uh on
as i said in my testimony on other
applications i would like to have
another application
the state legislature my 100 years
and
so the only hazard on this one is
that
whether it's a hazard or not
um is that congress could write it and
the term limits amendment were balanced
by the amendment in such a way that it
doesn't do anything
and then they send it down to
they they realize that we're people
actually read the amendments
and
accused that they didn't
uh they might choose state ratifying
manuals and put an amendment that
doesn't have any teeth
so
the the danger is that they'll just
continue to breathe
case scenarios
if we can just speak a little hour
that
the risks do not
the risk definitely
i would say that there's no reason
there's no risk
there's no downside on this one there
are
there out of 600 applications there are
some where they should call for generic
constitutional convention this
um
i don't i don't think that there's a
risk
uh
there's an outside possibility that they
can take one of these funds with all
three of the single visits
we already have potential hundred years
of runaway
conference congress
san constitutional amendments down space
company just want to do it
um
usually congress is responding to we and
the state
responses
if they said we're going to disregard
this
amendment you could make that
legislation
actually hold one second i apologize uh
representative javi had here first
representative
thank you i don't have a question but um
and i couldn't figure out a way to um
just post a chat um a comment
uh representative abram i can't hear
representative abramson at all i don't
know where the microphone is in the room
but um it's not your hearing mr chair
i can't hear him either
but i don't feel bad now thank you
all right can you hear me now yes i can
that's so much better thank you
okay
representative
so i'll um
i have kind of a twofold question i'll
ask for a follow-up mr chairman but
thank you for recognizing me mr chairman
thank you our representative
for your testimony today for taking that
question um is there any guidelines or
restrictions in article 5 convention as
laid out in the uh constitution and what
is the latitude of action that the
convention can take when amending our
rights in the constitution we're mending
how our countries operate
um that's a fantastic question um
on the second part of that what latitude
do they have the constitution actually
restricts what can be done for example
the 17th amendment we used to elect our
senators indirectly
and in other words voters went through
the state legislature to elect senators
because the senate was just supposed to
be a check on the power of all the other
parts of the government
the senate became more and more powerful
so the 17th amendment was just just
clearly violates uh the constitution in
my opinion
so the constitution
says you can't pass the 17th amendment
that went through it was an active new
year
so
that's taken away
part of our ability to use the state
legislatures
government so even though the
constitution on paper it says you can't
do this
um
political class kind of did it
roe v wade's another example where
um
you know
although the constitution says this you
don't speak up a little louder oh and
i'm too far from microphone right now it
does
um
so the constitution has all these
protections in
but if
the bulk of people in washington dc just
continue to disregard it and even if the
us supreme court doesn't enforce it it
doesn't get enforced all right thank you
did i have a follow-up right so i just
want to point out one thing is that two
men needs to make a change so obviously
if they you know
if our federal government you know
decides to make a change for a
constitution and it goes you know with
direct transition position to a you know
past uh
to pass clause and constitution and
existing class the point of the
amendment is to make a change so you
know to um
improve the constitution or you know
however but my other question is um how
would rules be adopted for such a
constitutional on foreign
is there specific guidelines in the
constitution that's saying that when
he had a state and a number of states
asked for a constitutional change to be
made what's preventing such a convention
from adopting rules that give them
unlimited latitude to change the
constitution however they want is there
any kind of guideline restrictions
within the constitution let's say do you
have to
only in this article 5
convention address this specific issue
or can they enter into a convention and
just have a wide latitude of rules and
make what kind of memorables for working
and mending the constitution as they'd
like
okay well
they they can submit all sorts of things
um please yep um
should i not speak
a lot of it please okay
all right um
so the question is you know
if i'm correct could it turn into a
runaway convention just on their own
rules um
article 5 sorry
articles of confederation
uh allow the runaway convention
and james madison when he wrote this
decided he didn't want to have a runway
convention so he's very clear about
using the word purpose
we can call for an amendment a specific
amendment for proposing amendments
there are four types of applications one
is
uh
just a handful of states that call for
an open convention
constitutional convention where they can
do
pretty much
anything
um and they're most applications are
based on a purpose or a general issue
some say
here's what we want change specifically
like a pro-life amendment or something
and then a few the state legislature
will actually write the wording to put
quote unquote exactly what they want
inserted in the constitution
um
and
i don't think that the
just a general constitutional convention
application is a good idea and i'm not
sure that that even complies with
article five i think that that you have
to have a specific purpose and you have
to say
here's what we want here's what we're
willing to ratify when it comes back
um
and by the way when you need three
quarters of the states to ratify
there's never been as i said there's
never been an article 5 convention
there's never been a convention of the
states but when congress has sent
amendments down
that
the state legislatures didn't agree with
they just
there's no way that you're going to get
three quarters of the states to ratify
either by
uh state legislature or nominating or
ratifying convention there's no way that
you're going to get it approved if they
send anything other than
essentially what we've sent up there
mr chairman
oh god yeah um thank you again for you
know my question thank you for
recognizing again mr chairman so
basically what i'm taking away from this
is that
there is no set guideline to how an
article 5 convention works other than
current interpretation by scholars there
are scholars who might say that they
have a lot of latitude their people
might describe the opinion that you have
that you know there has to be specific
latitude with purpose but it has been
tested so in theory
could
a constitutional convention decide that
they're going to convene for a purpose
of something but then adopt rules with a
wide latitude as i can see um
that's never happened um about article 5
conventions narco 5 conventions never
happened interpreting it the way
congress has the closest we had to a
convention in the states was the u.s
senate for the first
130 years 120 years or so
um
so that's kind of how
when we were sending our deputies to
washington dc wherever the location will
be for conventional states
we can kind of predict how they would
behave because we already know
we had the u.s senate for 130 years that
were deputies sent by the state
legislatures and they were usually state
legislators we sent
up up to up to uh congress to limit the
power of the federal government
um
so
uh what rules are in place essentially
is it's all the states choosing the
deputies it's it's the people it's john
ada john adams and thomas jefferson had
two different ways of limiting
government um jefferson wanted the bill
of rights by the way the bill of rights
came out of
um
virginia new york applying
for a general broad purpose hey we need
a bill of rights out of the constitution
um that was done through article five
um
jefferson thought that a bill of rights
would restrain federal power because he
just wanted to protect the rights of the
individual john adams was more
interested in protecting the
creating the structure of government
where each branch acted as a check on
the power of the other so we got both we
got both the federal system and a
republican all right
thank you
we've got to move on if i may uh
representative lebranch
you have a question
yes thank you mr chair and thank you uh
representative abramson for coming to
introduce the spill or this uh house
concurrent resolution
uh my question is to address the fears
of many people
of a runaway convention i personally
don't believe that that is a concern
uh so my question is
uh isn't any proposed amendment coming
from a convention having to be adopted
by the several states afterwards
yes has to be adopted by 38 states
unfortunately
congress gets to choose either by state
ratifying convention
either the state ratifying convention or
the uh state legislature they've almost
always gone with state legislatures um
but
i there with some of the other
applications that are out there there
actually is a risk
some of the other applications there i
think there are four or five out there
from other state legislatures that do
call for just a constitutional
convention with no purpose
um so i think that we have to be careful
with how we word these
um and i have with both hcr 1 and hcr4
to be very specific not just what is the
purpose you know not just what is the
issue but here's what we want the
amendment to do
so that that's out there in front of the
public and then when that matter comes
back to the state legislatures or goes
back to the voters the voters can see
were you really following your the
instruction sent that we sent through
our state legislatures
or did you just
you know come up with a ban on ar-15s or
something that you just wanted to do
you know i i think that uh
what is it 34
states are republican right now 30 yeah
34 so there would be 34 the delegates
would be republican
so i think what would come back would
probably be
more conservative leaning
favoring limited government
in terms of what comes
back um
but you might get something that's
bipartisan
um but i
i think the rules were pretty clear that
uh you know right from 1789
uh whatever comes back from either
congress or a convention of the states
would have to stick to whatever
plan the legislature specified
all right like um jay repeat that for
number three no no that's that's right
uh if i may i want to ask you um
just so you know new hampshire had did
have a convention um constitutional
convention back in 1978
and what that brought was article 73a
you operated the damage that's into the
state of new hampshire and the judicial
system yeah and that's actually an
excellent point the voters approved
sorry
you're right on the state constitutional
convention which follows a different
path the voters only approve the first
two sentences of uh was it article 73 or
73 right yeah and then
the third sentence which basically gives
the
the new hampshire supreme court
you know the power of law
which is
absolutely absurd and
runs contrary to the rest of the
constitution but that that's uh that's
this one that's the state constitution
and second
they didn't follow the process at all
and i'm not quite sure how that third
sentence got in there it's never been
randomized okay thank you
you don't have to answer this and the
reason why i bring this up for all the
listeners to know
what happened in new hampshire that the
supreme court now
the rules so promulgated shall have the
force and effect of the law
just to give you an idea of what the
cartesian adventure did to new hampshire
okay if there were any are there any
other questions
okay yes thank you thank you mr speaker
um and thank you representative
um
he just said that
this event happened in new hampshire
and they didn't follow the process
but i read the and believe me i'm no
constitutional lawyer but i read the
uh you know one sentence that is article
5 in our constitution
and although it's a long sentence
it doesn't
detail any specific procedures
i mean it details some authority
is there another document that details
exactly what has to happen during the
convention and has that has there been
any definitive rulings from the supreme
court
on
what a convention needs to
before he answers that if any members
brought in lunch you want to get up and
go eat your lunch please do that
okay uh because this is going on a lot
longer than we expected so
and any members that are watching
i won't hurt me if you've eaten a
sandwich
right
that's that's an excellent question um
we've we've talked about that the
article five group um there's never been
an article five convention like i say
some of the other applications that are
out there
could lead to a convention of the states
hcr one will never lead to a convention
in the states congress would never allow
it but but what would happen
hypothetically is
um
i think it would just operate like all
the other legislative bodies where
it's just assumed we have the right to
kind of come up with our own
house rules
so to speak if they're going to follow
masons or not if that if if you're
referring to the procedure whether or
not it gets broken up into committees
and subcommittees and task forces and
that kind of thing
that's part of the reason why some state
legislatures will only submit an
application says
here's the wording that we want so that
all the discussion happens here at the
legislative one members of the committee
want to change this application to
something that's really specific
to do that that's fine but
as far as there being
you know some document out there already
that would set the rules and procedure
for how the convention of the states
would operate even where they would meet
none of that is set that would just kind
of have to be
thank you
okay um
um so there is no set procedure from my
understanding and you're telling me that
in this case
we're absolutely sure it wouldn't go
anywhere else
but
i hear that from a lot of people on
other matters where they say this could
never happen or that could never happen
when i see it
so i was really looking for something
more concrete that would
establish that and ensure it does
nothing
if i can uh
he's not a constitutional lawyer and
okay it's an opinion that you know what
might could have happened so we'd be out
going down a different path here that
could go on and on am i right uh
representative
uh well i i do have more knowledge of
this than
99 of people can you answer them in 30
seconds
that we what we haven't already heard
yes you answered i'm saying there will
be other people testifying
know even more about her
all right thanks i just think that's
that's a question that could drag on and
on opinion and without somebody actually
did you trust me okay um seeing that
there are no other questions i thank you
very much um i want to uh bring on um
joseph torelli
who supports the position
is joseph available joseph
if there's a way you cannot be
repetitious we appreciate it
and if you keep going on and on like
other people i'm just gonna have you
have muted thank you
available
okay
[Music]
i'm
i'm having a little uh internet issues
uh
new hampshire a little bit uh
and so forth
thank you mr chairman for recognizing me
i appreciate the opportunity to testify
uh in favor in support of hcr1
i sent out uh effectively uh
[Music]
as well as supporting it with the
petition signers in each of your
districts
um i urge you to read it if you haven't
already
there's a lot of information in there in
a short amount of time
one of the things i want to raise is the
fact that we have checks and balances in
our government
one of the sections in my testimony my
written testimony is that as we've seen
last year and again now this january the
legislative branch has a way of checking
the executive branch
the
executive branch has a way of checking a
legislative branch with a veto
and the judiciary can send things back
to the legislative branch and what
article 5
allows us to do as the people allows you
as the state legislatures to do around
the country
is to provide a method of giving we the
people
through you the state legislatures
the ability to put a check on all three
of the branches
this is a big deal as we look at 30
million 30 30 trillion dollars in debt
now
as we look at
40 new executives
in
well let's see it's coming up on the
10th day
of this administration
there needs to be a method by which
we the people have a method of being
able to fix things
one of the things that's been said for
many years is the government closest to
the people is the best government
because we will not ever see senator
shaheen and a hannaford or senator
hassan in a shaw's
we will see you guys
at
doors or at the home depot
we will get to talk to you we can help
to influence you because you're close to
us
and so as we take that group of i think
it's 8 500 now petition signers uh for
an article 5 convention for proposing
amendments
in your districts
i almost a thousand i think
last night i looked it was very close to
a thousand in your individual districts
of the 20 districts represented by the
21 committee members
we are all
people that pay attention when it comes
time for primaries we we pay attention
when it comes time for the general
election
we need to have our voices heard and
we're not going to hear it coming out of
dc from the elites so i thank you for
your for your um
[Music]
effort to to
hear this and listen to it
thank you joe
is there anything we have an opportunity
to have this in front of the
the entire floor of the house
thank you very much and i yield whatever
time there may be left
thank you
when we passed you three minutes but
thanks
representative yeah thank you for um
thank you for recognizing mr chairman
and thank you mr cereal for your
testimony i was just wondering i
couldn't hear it because you cut it out
the beginning of where are you from and
what's your professional background
okay i am a i am a recovered journalist
i was with nbc news for 13 years
covered 76 countries major events that
you've seen in the 70s 80s and 90s
i reside now in ham hampshire
where are you from
where am i from born and raised in miami
florida
where do you live now please hampton new
hampshire
thank you are there any other questions
and there's no other questions thank you
joe
the next uh speaker
louis
spencer
the available
and lewis
opposes the bill
okay let's move on to the next one
torrence
uh for lewis if you're available put
your hand up and we'll come back to you
uh the next one is karen waldron
and he supports stability
you've got three minutes please keep it
in three minutes
are you there
he's still a mute
parents could you unmute please thank
you okay how's that working
that's great right
i'll go a little faster i'm a resident
of uh east kingston new hampshire for
the record but 233 years ago we became
the ninth state to ratify this
constitution of the united states so in
essence new hampshire had a very leading
role in that we actually physically put
the constitution in force in the
constitution article 5 empowers
the states to request a convention to
propose amendments to this constitution
i'm going to pause there for a second
because questions came out about how
this can be controlled
the control mechanism is obviously the
approval of those amendments and that is
the
ratification by 38 states to approve it
that is the major control mechanism
but this tool was put in the
constitution
as
a way for the uh for the states to
restrain a runaway federal government
the power this power was actually
retained by the states it wasn't given
to the states because the states had all
the power
as a check on federal power
by all reasonable measures i think we
can all agree
in many aspects of federal government
is already run away
as state legislators
we citizens of new hampshire empower you
with responsibility to protect our
interests
from the excesses of the runaway federal
government
the only tool in your tool shed
is article five
that is a way you can constrain a
runaway federal government
personally i feel as your moral
obligation to act
to check a runaway federal government
it's morally unconscionable to me
that you allow the federal government to
continue spending us into bankruptcy
just in the simplest form
we have a fox out there congress it's
killing off the livestock
that a farmer depends on to sustain its
family
the farmer is given a weapon that can
drive the fox away that weapon is
article five it's a powerful weapon and
the farmer feels that the fox can turn
the weapon around on him
what is the farmer to do does he hunker
down in his house and keep the weapon
sheathed hoping the problem goes away we
all know the result will be nothing but
ruin for the farm and his family stars
or the farmer can utilize the weapon
article 5
to drive the fox away
in a legal manner that safeguards his
family
we all know the correct approach
the family must be protected
i ask you to do your duty to the people
of new hampshire
and protect the people from a runaway
federal government
advance hcr one with a positive
recommendation thank you
well thank you terrence uh being a
writer with a journalist how you are
are you aware that the state of new
hampshire has already did their farmer's
job
and uh we're on record for a balanced
budget uh type
uh constitution convention at
in d.c
what a vital
28 states something like that have
already on record are you aware of that
i'm aware that you voted to rescind that
balanced budget uh in the last uh
well
session of this legislature and that
bill went to the floor and was placed on
the table yes i am aware of it i was at
all the hearings
i don't support it i mean i made a
mistake when i passed it
i just didn't want the implication to be
on the floor that you were supporting it
sir
right now i'm asking you about this bill
yes sir
are you aware that we are on record the
balanced budget regardless whether i try
to repeal it or not where are you you
understand that right i i am
thank you i'm aware of that yes sir
are there any questions
you see and none okay let's move on to
um
al brandino brandon oh we already got
help um disregard that
uh let's go on to eric bell
eric bell
he supports
christine eric's surroundings
oh
okay
eric you got three minutes please keep
it in three minutes we're way over our
schedule
yes chairman you can hear me okay
okay great
uh my name is eric bell i am a resident
of plaistow new hampshire adopted me
back in 1991 and i believe is a great
move um
i do support a convention of states
article 5 convention
and you've heard different things today
well
my argument is really to quell a fear
as opposed to anything more affirmative
i believe fully in a convention of
states article 5 convention
there are several fears and some have
been voiced today the one i want to
address is a runaway convention
i believe that stems from the same
information i was given as a child back
in the 60s i'm a product of the 60s and
at that time they said people were sent
to fix the articles of confederation our
first constitution
and instead they scrapped it
in their own way and then created a
second our second constitution the one
we live under today
and that was a runaway it was people
doing the wrong thing they straight
outside the lines of their original
commissions
okay i'm going to submit this evidence
that universities the university of
wisconsin yale university they all have
archives of documents each of the
commissioners the people who went to
that congress
to work on the
redrafting were given commissions the
commissions were laid out by the
legislatures these are documents people
don't go places and represent other
people you all have documentation saying
you sit
in your seats as you do because you have
commissions to do that you want
elections this is the way it works the
same thing was true for those people
11 of those commissions there were 13 13
colonies 11 of those commissions
say nothing whatsoever about maintaining
the articles of confederation they said
in short i'm paraphrasing just fix the
situation
new york and massachusetts two of the
other three were dead set against just
that and they wanted to fix it and rhode
island sat out
new hampshire in 1787 sent their
commissioners again it's a one-page
document for them that says nothing
about maintaining a status quo
just fix it is the summation
and so they did they came up with a new
document
there's nothing against that
but back in the 60s it started where
people were being told about runaways
and they were being told about people
straying outside the lines and and
chairman when you talk about what
happened in new hampshire i understand
that you're right to have a fear for
what happened in new hampshire i'm only
addressing the fear that lives within
almost everybody that this will be a
runaway i might have more to speak on it
but instead i just wanted to address
that there were strict commissions given
to people they stayed within their
boundaries and they did their job
and i thank you very much i do
respectfully ask that this bill get
moved for debate in the full house
i'll take any questions thank you very
much
thank you very much
you retain the bill or not
so there is a
difference there than other states but
anyways uh do we have any questions uh
whatever
none okay thank you very much
thank you all
okay uh the next um ken quinn who
supports he's speaking for himself ken
if you could tell us where you're from
and it's up to three minutes thank you
ken quinn he's on the phone last eight
seconds good morning can you hear me now
let me hear you hi
good morning my name is ken quinn i'm
from bridgton maine chairman baldacero
distinguished committee members i want
to thank you for allowing me to speak
here i'm speaking on behalf of myself
and not
an organization i've been in the article
5 arena now for about 8 years i've been
before your committee a number of times
i want to really address
just one specific thing and you can look
at my um testimony my written testimony
it's about the rules one thing i hear
often and i've heard it this morning is
that we don't have rules for an article
5 convention
and i want to explain
why they did not put that in the
constitution because they didn't need to
because they were so used to having
conventions they understood how they
operated in fact
our country has had hundreds of
conventions conventions of states and uh
even
most notably is the annapolis convention
of 1786 which was called for commerce
issues
they recommended that the philadelphia
convention be held for the next year i
highly recommend you read federalist 40
by james madison he just he completely
refutes the charge
that the philadelphia convention
exceeded their authority they had full
rights to to adopt a new constitution
one fascinating part of history is that
we have even had two conventions of the
states that have met to propose a uh
actually several
amendments to the u.s constitution and
new hampshire has participated in both
of them the washington peace conference
of 1861 and the hartford convention of
1814.
every year a confederat
a convention of states is held
all 50 states participated it's called
it was called the national conference of
commissioners on uniform state laws is
more commonly known as the unifor
uniform law commission
this
body functions exactly as an article 5
convention would function the scope is
predetermined and limited the
commissioners are appointed by you the
state legislatures
or the governors but in new hampshire
it's the legislature that appoints the
commissioners they arrive and they
present their credentials which allows
them on what topics they are able to
discuss draft and they debate uh uniform
state laws
the vote is taken by state so it's one
state one vote passed by a majority and
then whatever passes those commissioners
bring the model act back to their state
legislature to try to adopt it as state
law in fact right now your house
judiciary committee
h.b 124 is a model act passed by an
official convention of the states
further history the state of themselves
and this is where new hampshire just
shines there has been
233 conventions
in the states to either adopt a new
constitution or propose amendments to
their current constitutions
new hampshire leads the nation at 17.
two of those conventions were called to
adopt a new constitution and 15 of those
were called to propose amendments out of
those 15 conventions 261 amendments were
proposed and the people ratified
129 of them so
of all the states in our country that
should be leading
this charge to call an article 5
convention should be new hampshire in
fact in 2017
your legislature sent seven legislators
as delegates to another official
convention of states the phoenix
convention which was called by the state
legislature of arizona to adopt official
rules for an article 5 convention which
they did i would highly recommend that
you would speak to your
legislators that attended that they can
provide you the
actual rules i can send those to you as
well if you would like there are so many
rules that are there are actually other
organizations like the assembly of state
legislatures that have adopted rules for
an article 5 convention and the american
legislative exchange council among
others so it's not that we don't have
the rules
what we need are people to actually
start using these rules that are well
established and vibrant and have been
working for us for over 200
years and that is why i'm here in
support of hcr one because
the previous testimony is right what is
it going to take to get our state
legislatures to stand up
to a federal government that refuses to
listen to the will of the people
tramples our rights our freedoms and
it's up to you
it's your duty under article 5 to defend
our freedoms and our liberties and to
use the authority that the framers gave
you
through this process because if you do
not
nothing will ever change and we will
continue into a spiral downhill so i
want to thank you for your time and be
more than happy to answer any questions
and if you don't have time for that
today please email me i have lots of
information to prove that it's a limited
convention thank you and i want to thank
you i i i've known you before coming in
here and i know you have a lot of
information for a lot of people have a
lot of information against and
a lot of people have stuff in between so
believe me we fully understand that
somebody's been on this committee for 14
years
but my question to you is
on the convention of states that you
call for
uh i mean that's just you know the 50
states getting together and
you know coming up with you know on what
they could be or what you might want to
bring up or whatever but the bottom line
is it's not a constitutional convention
because there's no requirements for
those people that attended to go into
that convention of states go back to
your state and you have to file an
amendment it's nothing that comes under
an article 5. am i correct real yes or
no
are you referring to the union law
commission
that i referenced
a convention of states are you talking
about no a convention of states uh no it
cannot be amended whatever comes out of
that convention cannot be amended it has
to be adopted as written and as approved
by the convention
right but
follow up here what i'm trying to say in
it but it cannot be held the states
don't have to go back and file it like
it would a constitutional convention am
i right yes or no
file what exactly i don't understand i'm
sorry chairman
um so you mentioned these rules
regarding an article 5 conventional
convention of the states i'm not sure
what the differentiation is there but my
question is what is the latitude of
action within these rules can a
convention decide not to adopt these
rules there's nothing in the
constitution that requires them to put
off these rules that you are apparently
cited so could there be a fear that they
just adopt a different set of rules that
um are contrary to
the desires of the previous rules that
you
cite
well
my testimony shows that we have had so
many of these conventions of states that
the idea that we don't understand how
one would operate is just not based on
any fact or logic based upon our
experience
all a convention of the states is is the
states having a meeting they draft
a proposal
depending on what it was called for it's
limited to the call and you control them
by your commissions
so they they are actually legally bound
they are agents of the principle the
principle being the state legislature
and the rules adopted would be the rules
that your legislators have also already
adopted in the 2017 convention or any of
the other
rules that have been adopted and used
they're all very similar
and there is really
this is not recreating the wheel here
it's it's quite just this is how these
things operate and it's time we actually
start using it and not be fearful of it
it's
is there that a conceivable universe
where they adopt a different set of
rules that are different than previous
worlds that could have competable
outcomes that are bad for the american
people
well you control which rules they adopt
so in your commissions you could specify
which rules to adopt so if you prefer
the rules from the assembly of state
legislators you can put in your
commission that they would adopt those
rules this can be all done ahead of time
before the convention even meets and so
it's up to the state legislatures to put
that within their commissions
they work for you
if i may
add on
this is what al baldur syria but in 1784
uh did they do something similar that
new york two uh legislators or two
voters walked away
and then they couldn't get back in and
all the votes were done secret
and well
i believe you
i i believe you're referring to the
philadelphia convention is that correct
yes
yeah so that's a great example of how
this is limited the new york delegation
their commission only allowed them to
revise the articles of confederation so
they were limited by that when they
arrived the convention was called well
beyond ex the expansion of the articles
and so because they were not allowed to
go beyond revising the articles they
were limited and so that is why they
left the constitutional convention in
fact after they left new york no longer
had a vote now
alexander hamilton came back and he
signed the constitution but uh his votes
or his signature did not even count and
so it was actually ratified by what 11
11 states and so that just proves again
how the commission of those new york
delegates they were bound to it and that
is why they left the convention
thank you again uh real quick if so uh
if i may yes or no doesn't that prove
the fact that then a state making up
their own rules
because every state is going to have 50
separate set of rules that goes down to
a conscious convention
that
they don't have to comply with that
state
uh yes or no
no
because the the the the states
the commissions are not the rules of the
convention the rules of the convention
are adopted once the convention begins
the commissions
bind and only allow
what the delegates who are sent
it only provides them the authority to
vote on what they were sent to do and so
that would be
written up and drafted by this each
state legislature giving them their
authority to represent the principle
so no they it has nothing to do with the
rules
you could you could recommend that the
delegation
accepts particular rules
and then it would all be based on the
vote of the convention which rules to
adopt but the long story said we have
the rules we know how it works we use
them even today every single year and
it's time that we finally do
thank you uh seeing that are there any
other questions
okay
thank you ken thank you
let me see here who's next bob hanson
um up to three minutes please
and uh everyone else i know we're
running late on the uh
when you're doing a zoom you don't know
until the morning you're coming in on
how many people are going to testify or
not robert hanson could you recover did
you raise your
hand as an attendee oh yeah you have to
thank you and if you could let us know
where you were testifying uh where you
from
thank you
my name is
hjn scn i'm a u.s navy veteran i'm a uh
registered independent from salem new
hampshire
um i've submitted an email with my
testimony i wasn't sure i'd be able to
get here today but after listening to
what's going on i'm gonna make some
alterations
last night i happened to read
in a letter that was written in
opposition by somebody who followed the
john birch society
and i'm speaking in support of moving
the resolution but i'd like to read his
comment there were two sentences
quote
our constitution is currently much too
vulnerable to a runaway an unorganized
agenda
developed inserted by politically based
special interest groups for self-serving
purposes
into the whims of our corrupt
politicians which we are becoming famous
for
end quote
notice that was his first sentence and
when i read it it strikes me as a
perfect description of the current
situation we have in congress
the first sentence was followed
immediately by the second sentence
quote
it's essential that our constitution
remain intact
and exactly
as our founding fathers provided
his second sentence to me is the reason
that we have the corrupt situation the
first sentence so by his own words he
proves that changes to the constitution
are necessary or nothing will change
the powers of the convention of states
are
very limited but they're identical to
what we have in the congress right now
i feel that the congress is the perfect
example of a runaway convention
in the congress of states we're going to
have up to 50 people who can propose an
amendment
in the existing congress we have almost
600 individuals who can propose an
amendment
every day
they can propose the amendment on any
topic
convention that we are proposing is
defined that will only make changes to
an existing constitution it's not going
to create a new constitution
and it's limited to three areas and
those three areas are to limit the
powers of the government
we are not proposing that we
limit anything to an individual we're
not going to propose amendments and we'd
not be allowed to propose an amendment
that prohibits someone from doing
something or mandates that they do
something
we are limited to proposing things that
the federal government can do and cannot
do
um
as an example
this past week ted cruz just proposed an
amendment
to uh term limits
um that's great news
but
as you watch this proceed you're going
to find that the current legislators
will never let this go through
in the email that i sent is a an
attachment that's got a history of term
limit proposals
and i'm not trying to take a position
for or against term limits
but i just want to
provide the history to show
that in the 200 plus years there have
been several attempts to impose term
limits as amendments
those proposals never got to the states
for their three-quarters of people vote
those proposals never get out of the
committees and never get to the floor
for consideration
we have a situation
where
the congress are not going to propose
amendments that are against their
interests their self-interest
all right
you hear me um
one final thing
as far as
the convention getting out of
control the supporters of this
convention were believers of the
existing constitution
there's no interest or ability to
eliminate the existing one
we're clearly not non
we're clearly non-radicals we're not
rioting we're not burning we're not
threatening anyone
we're working within the system we're
following the law
we're using the peaceful tools that were
provided for us in article 5.
we must use article 5 to provide the
intended government by the people
the federal government is only supposed
to have those powers explicitly
enumerated in the constitution
all of the powers belong exclusively to
the states we must get those powers back
to the states
i respectfully request the committee
move the debate to the full house where
it can be fully vetted and debated by
both parties on its merits in the best
interest all new hampshire voters
thank you for your consideration
thank you mr hanson and
remind them
who gets your emails
good look at them
is on our speaker list uh rooks and the
chase can we uh yeah we can bring out
the nominee
can you hear me
yes yes general uh you may proceed
good morning representatives it's an
honor to speak with you today thank you
for all you do for our great steak i
know many of you i've been in your homes
i've been standing shoulder to shoulder
with you uh i know we all have our
country and the state of new hampshire's
best interests in mind and i thank you
for the opportunity to speak to you
today my name is don baldick i'm from
stratham new hampshire
i am a patriot and i would never do
anything to undermine our constitution
and i think
uh and i would pick up a rifle tomorrow
and stand to post as i know many of you
would too if our country needed us to
i support hcr one a resolution applying
for a convention for proposing
amendments under article 5 of the united
states constitution we are at a point in
our country's great history where the
diligent work of our framers is being
abused more often and in many cases
lately
completely ignored by the three branches
of our government
our government is out of control at the
federal level our government of the
people by the people and for the people
is in danger the federal government is a
runaway government not a control right
now
the people need to act
the federal government will not change
until we get people down to washington
dc
that will actually work for the people
but that is another two years away
as you know i am a declared candidate
for the united states senate running
against maggie hassan
and i am concerned about this issue
because we're not going to get any help
from that delegation
um
my platform is consistent with balancing
the budget fiscal responsibility
limiting government and establishing
term limits
this is what this convention estates is
about
i joined tom cotton paul ryan and ted
cruz in these efforts
they need our help a convention of
states is our way of doing this
my only request is and it's respectfully
request that the committee allow this to
go on to the house floor for debate and
vote
thank you all and god bless you all
live free or die
[Music]
okay
all right thank you um
to my fellow republicans you all know
that i just came back from club right
yeah i'm going to put this on because i
don't want any of the democrats on the
screen to get coping
okay i know you all don't have an issue
there and uh i've been social distance
everywhere i went but they're all
winding and playing and who's reporting
so let me make them happy there and play
the game here okay because i don't want
anyone on these tv screens to get cold
i'm saying so let's play the game
but anyways make a long story shot
general i want to thank you there for uh
you're testifying
and uh
do i have any questions for that
representative
thank you mr chairman for uh recognizing
me thank you general bulldog for your
testimony i just have um one quick
question what would be more helpful
helping balancing our federal budget
more speed
um
trying to
or electing yourself to the us senate
against
[Music]
i am i'm still here but i need to uh can
you hear me
okay great hey thank you for that
question well i think they're both great
avenues uh to uh to promote change
change on behalf of our great state here
uh finally getting someone down there to
work for you and join forces to do that
so i appreciate your question but i
support both avenues thank you
thank you mr general
all right are there any other questions
i guess
i will agree to disagree
that's okay i i love you al you know it
hoorah you're the band
thank you very much general uh keep up
the great work and we appreciate you
testifying god bless you next year
uh
um are you available
okay welcome gerunds please uh three
minutes we want to move on uh we've been
on way past here
thank you and tell us where you're from
hello
i'm yourself please terrance
parents are you there i've asked you to
meet yourself
if you want you can send in your
testimony uh to the committee there
okay um there's one person with their
hand crazy this is
clear
okay who is it mark meckler
yes that's uh
uh mr chairman can you hear me
thank you mr chairman honorable members
of the committee my name is mark meckler
i'm an attorney who resides in texas and
i'm the co-founder and the president of
citizens for self-governance and the
convention of states project
just briefly i'd like to open by
thanking you for your service mr
chairman semper fi my son is a united
states marine
my father served honorably in the united
states army in world war ii and is a
bronze star recipient so thank you and
god bless you for your service sir
the convention of states application has
been passed in 15 states already it
applies to congress under an article 5
of the u.s constitution for a convention
to propose amendments that would impose
fiscal restraints on washington dc limit
federal power and jurisdiction and set
term limits for federal officials i
support hcr one to the extent that it
does this
i think that we are at a time in
american history where the federal
government is clearly out of control and
something needs to be done to restrain
them the disagreement among at least
those of us on the right side of the
aisle is what is the appropriate
methodology and i do understand and
appreciate that debate and the cares and
concerns of both sides
i am a constitutional attorney by
training i've spent approximately the
last 10 years as a subject matter on
this expert i am one of the leading
subject matter attorneys on the history
and use of article 5 in the united
states of america today
i i would request that you pass hcr one
and i'd be happy to open myself for open
myself for questions and i'll reserve
the rest of the time for that mr
chairman in in honor and respect of the
time constraints on the committee today
well thank you
uh does anyone have any questions for uh
see you none um thank you very much um
is there anyone else out there that
we've missed uh that wants to go
[Music]
representative matt agent could
introduce the bill
welcome uh representative if you can
like i said please speak a little louder
because when you're back to georgia it's
kind of hot you got some old-time
veterans in here that like me have
served with artillery
you know i hear him go away after a
while
i didn't know that you were in desert uh
desert storm yeah
because i was too young for vietnam but
i
i'm not like the general there you know
i mean it went about 10 times but i i
went once
all right my name is representative max
abramson for the record i represent
hampton hampton falls and seabrook i'm
introducing house uh concurrent
resolution four
uh which simply
proposes to amend the constitution to
declare that
abortion is not a right under the
constitution i'll use the exact wording
in the resolution
oh i lost it
well here we go
uh the legislature of the state of new
hampshire makes this application to
congress
that convention be immediately called of
deputies from the several states for the
sole purpose of proposing an article
declaring that the right to abortion
is not secured by the constitution of
the united states
for that provision lines 10 through 13
i essentially copied the exact same
language as the very first
applications coming from the state of
new uh
state of virginia and new york when they
made their application that led to the
enactment of the bill of rights
i will make a disclaimer on this one
unlike hcr1
there is a possibility outside
possibility that hcr4
congress may not want to
draft the language themselves and they
could call a convention of the states
now i would
prefer
as it i would prefer as it says that we
do a convention of the states on this
one
and
uh the reason is
um that we have
generally majorities in the house and
senate that are not as amenable to this
um but the the effect of the amendment
would be if it passed
is that it would
essentially nullify roe v wade which is
actually no longer the law of the land
but it would also nullify
uh another decision
uh casey versus planned parenthood which
i think is a 1992 decision
which superseded roe v wade
roe v wade is used as the
uh example when people bring up judicial
activism the most common case that's
brought up
is roe v wade and the reason is
that this had been a states rights issue
for 200 years
of course this is new england we have
lots of small geographically small
states bunched together so the effect
has always been with small states
that you'll have some states banning
abortion at 24 weeks
some states are banned at 18 weeks some
states have have tried to ban it at
you know the second trimester
effectively that means that someone in
the second trimester only has to drive
across state lines but it is kind of a
matter of principle that
that this has always been a 10th
amendment issue
that the states had the right to enact
laws relating to informed parental
consent exceptions for rape incest
health of the mother
and
dealing with other cases voters had the
right to address these issues of
principle through their state
legislature not through the u.s supreme
court
and
the um oh there is a typo in the in the
um not a typo but
uh state of rhode island there i believe
14 or 15 states
that have approved this already someone
sent me an email
from cornerstone which does support a
convention in order to repeal roe v wade
by the way
that's a statement that they've had
public for a long time
they
couldn't find an application from the
state of rhode island so if members want
to delete that one
until we can actually find that
application
applications there are 600 applications
from state legislatures they're actually
really hard to track down i've read
of about 600 i've read almost 100 of
these applications
from state legislatures over the years
um
[Music]
essentially all i'm trying to do is
declare that as legislators
we're not going to stand by and allow
judicial activism and allow
judges or justices to simply
read things into the constitution that
the founding fathers would never
have intended
um there's absolutely no history or
constitutional law or anything of any
kind going back
you know to 1789 where the founding
fathers ever
or any constitutional scholar ever
thought that
that right to an abortion was something
under under federal law or under the
constitution it was has always been a
states rights issue
hopefully more states will
take this on and submit this application
unless we
add our state to the name and get the
ball rolling again uh i i don't think
that uh
these cases will be overturned
so with that i'll take questions okay
thank you
do we have any questions
[Music]
thank you
uh honorable chairman as i emailed you
i'm not sure if i'm going to testify
today um and so um if if i'd appreciate
um
checking back in with me at the end
thank you
you can always speak when we testify i
mean
[Music]
okay um representative i mean i'm
starting over
[Music]
um
can you put your hand up
okay let's move on to the next one um
ken quinn please tell us where you're
from and uh after three minutes thank
you
thank you uh ken quinn again uh bridget
maine and again i'm speaking on behalf
of myself as a
member of the public
i want to thank representative abramson
for introducing this resolution uh you
know our declaration of independence
states that we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal that they are endowed by the
creator with certain unalienable rights
that among these are life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness unquote
jefferson when he wrote that he didn't
say that all men are born equal they're
all created equal and hcr4 seeks to
protect the most basic
right known to mankind which is the the
right to life which begins at conception
um
far for for i'm sorry for far too long
the state legislatures have allowed our
constitution to be amended by usurpation
instead of by the provision under
article 5.
the supreme court has had judicial
decisions made judicial activism
decisions made which i would say roe v
wade is probably one of the the most
um
or the worst
what's so important here is that
in our amendment history four of our
amendments were proposed to overturn
decisions of the us supreme court
and that is the power of article five
the problem we have today is we're
letting the courts make the laws we have
presidents who are changing our laws
through executive orders i saw today the
president has issued 37 executive orders
so far
violating
and this is all the presidents obama
trump you name them they're violating
their oath of office and congress has
refused to do anything about this they
are expanding their powers abdicating
their legislative authority to
bureaucracies and it's only the states
that are sitting back and and letting
this happen when they have the duty and
the responsibility to push back and
change this on our behalf and so
unfortunately if we don't take action
through article 5 i do not see things
getting any better the the federalist 85
hamilton expressly
explains that article 5 is the ultimate
check against the encroachments of the
federal government and he says this
we may safely rely on the disposition of
the state legislatures to erect barriers
against the encroachments of the
national authority that was the purpose
they put the article 5 convention into
our constitution
and we are seeing encroachment on a
daily basis in closing i would just like
to share with you that congress has
introduced over 12 000 amendments to the
u.s constitution since 1789
while the states have introduced zero
amendments under article five
now
a lot of these amendments that congress
has have introduced are phenomenal
amendments but they will never see the
light of day because we can never get
enough members we need a two-thirds uh
to pass this in both the house and the
senate and they will not do that because
they want to maintain the status quo and
protect the establishment and so
what's important about this particular
resolution is that the states tried to
overturn this in the late 70s 19 state
legislatures applied for a convention
for a right to life amendment and it was
because of the efforts of
conspiracy groups like the john birch
society eagle forum which was led by
phyllis schlafly and the league of women
voters these groups
on both sides of the aisle
use the fear of a runaway convention by
getting people to doubt that we wouldn't
know how the rules would work that it
was a constitutional convention we
couldn't control it and so that fear
derailed the effort by the state
legislatures to get to a convention to
overturn roe v wade and so what i am
imploring you to do today
is that we need to
have fearless leaders that are are not
fearful of not knowing what the rules
are because as i mentioned in my
previous testimony we have the rules we
just need to use the rules that have
been provided to us
under article 5 to use the authority
that you the state legislators have
to push back against the overreach
of the federal government the judicial
activism of our courts
and the executive powers that we're
seeing being
abused by our presidents and so i leave
that up to you and i encourage you to
please support
and pass hcr 4. thank you
thank you very much for your testimony
do i have any questions
do you know okay thank you
yes
good afternoon mr chairman thank you uh
my name is jeannie herresca i'm from
concord new hampshire i'm the political
director for the american civil
liberties union of new hampshire and i
appreciate the opportunity to testify
today in opposition to hcr 4
and in opposition to calling for a
constitutional convention on any subject
matter
there is no language in the u.s
constitution that allows a convention to
be limited to just one issue
if a convention is called
it could be used to consider whatever
happens to the constitution delegates
choose
so
other entirely unrelated issues um
posing a dangerous threat to the u.s
constitution to our democracy
and to our civil rights quite simply
there are no guidelines or rules that
will govern a convention we have no
direct precedent it's unclear how
convention delegates would be picked
what rules would be in place what would
happen in the case of legal disputes or
how the american people and specifically
granite staters would be represented
so
in our view
regardless of your position on abortion
specifically the proposal for a
constitutional convention should be
concerning it's dangerous to convene a
convention about changing our
constitution when that convention would
have such few guard rails and it is for
these reasons that the aclu of new
hampshire respectfully asks this
committee to vote hcr4 and expedient to
legislate
all right well thank you
okay uh any questions
i don't see any questions i want to
thank you very much for your testimony
and thank you
anyone else that we've missed uh anyone
have the hands up
um
okay let's bring up uh that person who
please uh up to three minutes and if you
can uh
let us know
he's not a representative is he
no i'm not i'm actually thank you guys
so much i'm so sorry i missed my call
um a little bit of technical difficulty
um i am a resident physician at
dartmouth hitchcock medical center and
ob gyn
um and was um informed of this bill that
was
going up
uh in front of all you honorable
leaders of new hampshire
um i
am opposed to this bill based on nothing
more than what i see in my clinic
i
work with a passionate group of
physicians who are there for women's
rights and women's rights to choose
what they do with their body and how
they decide to do that
we see so many stories of patients
coming in
truly excited about the possibility of
motherhood and truly excited together
for their choice to proceed but things
happen outside of their control things
that devastate families things that
devastate their dreams their hopes
and have been in many situations where
i've had to hold the hands of patients
who have just been broken by
diagnoses that they had no control over
diagnoses that won't allow
um a appropriate life or a life outside
of the womb
and these decisions are not made lightly
they're not made because the woman
really um
you know has an option in terms of what
she decides to do um she does it out of
true love for her
or baby and i think you know when that
is what's that question or what's at
stake here when you're bringing up
the right to choose and deciding that
there is no right there i think that is
a true
um
a true setback for women that we see
every single day regular women who just
really want to have the best for their
lives and for their babies lives so
i would humbly request that you
reconsider
hcr4 and um do not push it
um forward questions for the doctor i
can just put you
seeing none
all right thank you very much um before
i close out i don't want to forget on
representative uh mandatory you so well
to speak
i've decided not to speak thank you
though for the opportunity
all right thank you
representatives
russell payne
okay russell uh yeah if you can
i thought we were getting out we're
ready to move on
all right go ahead
russell you there
going once
okay going twice
okay
mr payne you cannot speak now
you there mr payne
okay
mr pay can you hear us because if not
i'm gonna
take a 15-minute break before we go into
the one um are you
there okay
we gave it a shot okay with that there
uh mr payne before i close the committee
there one uh can use to make your
testimony to the committee because we
can't hear you we can see you there but
we can't hear you
okay so otherwise if you can submit that
there today a little while there so we
can take a look
and i thank you okay with that i'm going
to close inside of tr4
all right let me just get a handle where
we're at
now uh quarter one did y'all push on it
they're supposed to be delivered in 40
minutes sorry i don't know what time
that is now but
um
uh so
let's see here
[Music]
hey brad are you listening yes i am i'm
just i'm working on uh what
representative deschates was asking
yeah uh brad can you get in touch with
our um
committee administrator
and ask her if we can get the folders
for the bills because we're going to
need the blue sheets and the other in
order you know to uh write committee
reports and other stuff because i do
want to try to accept some of these
bills but i don't have the folders
all right i will uh reach out to her and
let her know
representative bel desaro
are we going to also be able to get
amendments to some of the the two hr's
um i will um i'm sure we can put them up
in the screen
uh on the amendments
you know i mean
uh bradley did because
okay and if we needed to caucus could i
respectfully ask for that
i wanted they're going to take you i
mean like us the republicans caught this
way before we even met so you told me
before you were practiced
no no we already caucus but i'm saying
that with the bills the hr's that have
amendments which we haven't seen nor had
a chance to look over
if we needed to caucus could we do that
okay hold on second who are the
republicans that did the amendments did
they send it to the democrats
or was the center committee um
uh yeah please say no i assume that i
sent it over
can you send that to the uh all the reps
the the amendment
you know you know what i mean to the
committee yes says the whole committee
i don't have i don't have representative
bin for its amendment but i have my
own i think i will get dave to do the
same
how does that looking
well if you if you could send them are
you going to break for uh lunch for 15
minutes you said
one o'clock is the next cousin
i can't hear you al
i mean
so i may open it up and then uh because
we have some pizzas coming uh
you know a lot of respect for the ones
that are here
you all can just sit at your house there
and in your job
no no
i understand that so um can we get the
amendments
sometime soon
what we're going to do
right now because i see david
can you email the amendment to the whole
committee
okay and then you're gonna take care of
the other one right
okay you should have in a few seconds
i'll take care of that problem okay
thank you
we also need to bring in the amendment
for the committee on those two bills
yeah
laurie what are we doing
tonight
thank you
mr chair for those um
[Music]
all right
you
oh
okay i want to welcome everyone back
for our
next uh bill
all right
so for the committee um
or for the bill files i believe those
are being maintained electronically
and right now they just have the bill on
them at the moment
he said they were maintained
electronically so there's no
part file
there's no hard problems so i have no
folders how do we um fill out the sheets
here with the amendment i mean with the
video reports
okay
no i'm missing
yes sir okay i want to open up the hdr5
and i want to introduce the
monta
which is
you should be uh
welcome to
uh thank you mr chairman
uh
so um
first of all thank you uh chairman baldr
zero and committee members for this
opportunity to introduce
hcr 5
a a
resolution regarding human rights and
democracy in hungary poland and hong
kong
i already submitted some written
testimony that you probably have all
received
so i'm just going to add a few personal
comments
and would be glad to entertain any
questions
i was born in budapest hungary and my
family fled the country in 1956
during the hungarian uprising against
the russian-controlled government
we were welcomed into the u.s first as
immigrants
and later on as citizens
as a result of my ethnic origin i have
been constantly in touch with relatives
and friends
in eastern european countries including
hungary poland the czech republic
and have kept abreast of the progress
that
was being made in democratic values and
governances in those countries
also i have worked as a caseworker for
amnesty international
on behalf of prisoners of conscience in
russia
and taiwan while it was still a military
dictatorship
and i found
a great deal of satisfaction to see that
some of these countries were able to
throw off a dictatorship or a one-party
rule and and have democratically elected
governments
that is why for me personally seeing
that the hungarian government currently
is reversing course and heading back to
a more authoritarian rule by one party
has been quite disappointing
i realize that this resolution today is
only as symbolic and symbolic in nature
since we are not in charge of our
country's foreign policies
however i don't i don't think that that
means that we cannot
that we can't express our sentiments
here regarding u.s foreign policy
and finally um
unfortunately we're meeting by zoom so
uh as a result of that i'm not able to
share with you some of
hunger hungary's famous apricot brandy
on a day that we could really use it
yes
so thank you for your attention i'd be
glad to entertain any questions
but anyways are there any questions or
anything from the committee
okay yes uh representative dilemmas
thank you chair
um thank you so much for coming and
presenting this uh hcr first a quick
question i know that we always refer to
democracy democracy democracy is there
any
what's happened to
a republican form of government is that
something that
no longer looking at to promote or is it
just a democracy all the way
uh thank you uh representative for your
question uh
i'm using the term democracy here or
democratic in a generic terminology
uh the way i interpret it is basically
allowing people to elect whatever form
of government they wish to have
so it's not a particular form of
government in fact you probably know
that most european countries
have a parliamentary democracy which
means
uh they elect the parliament and the
majority of the public the parliament
then elects their government so it's not
like our government here where we select
our president separate from the
representatives in congress so i'm using
the term democracy and democratic in a
generic term meaning people should be
allowed to elect the kind of government
that they want to represent them
thank you so much for that answer um
seeing that there's no other
are there any other questions or any
hands up there
uh
mr chairman can i just add a brief
remark um one of the motivations i had
for for proposing this bill was a
conversation i had with representative
john scitec
whose family originally comes from
poland
and after our conversation about the
issues going on in poland and i about
hungary uh that kind of motivated me to
bring out this resolution
i thank you very much
did a great job there i'm going to go
into exec on this bill
okay uh i'm going to open up the
executive session on house coverage and
resolution number five
and i am going to
uh representative brody uh you have a
motion
yeah i'd like some motion
is there a second a second okay uh
representative foster seconds it
uh uh okay do you want to discuss the
bill uh your motion there
yeah i think um i think this is a very
timely manner because he's built
considering the rise of authoritarianism
like china russia and iran and north
korea who oppress their people and
promote other regimes and groups that
are equally growing when we see this
growing
into constitutional republics and
constitutional monarchies
across um
specifically china actually cycled the
previously listed uh you know ideals of
democracy and freedom and equality in
places like hong kong
and uh stripping these 75 people have
of their own peoples we should express
our concerns as a comedian of the
legislature to ensure that we speak up
for those who do not practice such
freedoms in their own countries
democratic principles leads happier and
more fulfilling lives and greater a more
sustainable peace allowing people to
have a voice in their government to have
these freedoms fixed so then
we can have more
successful uh foreign policy and a more
successful and collaborative
go ahead
now i just want to
second what uh my colleague uh
representative deshay said i think this
is very timely and i think that this is
this is a good a good bill to uh hope
that hopefully our federal delegation
technologists
okay uh any other
anything else anyone else now i hope i'm
not missing anyone here my fellow
democrats are up here i'm looking
okay with that i don't see any hands up
uh as soon as the clerk is ready i'll
ask her for a roll call
uh now when you vote i want to make sure
that i can see that nobody will vote on
the phone
uh
jody
[Music]
okay
now keep in mind we have that mute
everyone it looks like
uh nothing was given it was for any roll
call or something like that crazy i
can't even believe it
noodles
this smells good
italian noodles
why
and if i miss someone please do not be
offended in any way i i don't know
hopefully you've got to hold it
last
ocean cover resolution number five
supporting democracy and human rights in
hungary poland and hong kong and
supporting democracy in taiwan and
alaska first let's take a roll call
yesterday
david
yes
i didn't know if you were calling my
name there this is
israel piedra
stacy marie could you please mute i
think we're getting some feedback from
yes
many despedia
um it's espitia and yes
yeah
yes
uh catherine harvey
yes yes
matt wilhelm
yes amanda toll
yes
tony lebron
stacey marie larkin
yes
that i want to just make sure i see you
voting
otherwise that vote won't come
yes
thank you yeah represent
and uh lawrenceville
yes
back to israel
i vote yes thank you madam clerk
thank you thank you representative thank
you
very much
anyone that we missed i think the one up
in the right hand want to get phyllis
source oh
excuse me pardon me
yes yes
okay
any democrats we got them all
[Music]
and let me see the next bill goes at
145 so
take a break
we're on the ball i wish the other ones
worked like this one here but life goes
on we're all doing a great job
this is all new to us
[Music]
rather
yes i am
i have right here in my hand
uh the committee report already done
uh i have an auto pass
but i have no fold i have no forms to
fill out i have nothing that needs to be
signed
i
my computer i can't use my finger and
sign on that so i need to so are you
looking for the
um
the paperwork for the reports or for in
for the
roll call sheets
i need roll call sheets i mean i need uh
okay i believe that would be through the
house clerk's office i will reach out to
them though
it comes from the committee um
i i don't even have an attendance list
that representatives sign off on okay i
will i will double check on this and
let you know as soon as possible
what do i do with the committee report
um you know the roll call that you had
to write it out
again i will check with um i will check
on that and get back to you
al
representative valdiserro
okay maybe this can go to um brad
brad nope
we cannot open
we cannot open the amendment
[Music]
i did this before
hey google
so
i'm going to do this
okay
people
down here
group
that's right let me tell you i want to
welcome everyone back to the committee
and
i'm checked here
and i want to welcome the prime sponsor
max representative
bit does it help if i
lean back and
bounce around
okay i'm uh representative max abramson
uh representing the good folks in
hampton hampton falls and seabrook
i'm introducing house resolution 7
which is
calling for the netflix movie cuties to
be taken off the air
and also asking the department of
justice to investigate
i assume that means having one of their
paralegals or somebody actually having
to watch the movie um
i understand that
rotten tomatoes has given the movie a
score of something like three percent
that only three percent of people like
the movie and none of those people will
admit to enjoying the film
uh
i was contacted by many many many people
who are upset about this film
and as soon as
i posted this on social media
um i wanted i had the idea of posting an
image so people know what film it was
but i couldn't find any image other than
just the poster for the movie and even
that was kind of
provocative um
there's an amendment that would just say
um change it to just condemning the film
cuties i
i don't agree with the
amendment
and the the reason is i think that it's
it's pretty
obvious
that the movie contains so much illegal
good graveyard here it is
the movie contains so much material that
violates 18 usc 2251 and 252
and i i would argue that it that it
isn't even really arguable
um
that it's that there were
apparently so many different laws broken
in the the making of this film
that
um
it's almost like it doesn't even need to
go to trial the problem that i saw from
reviewers and people on social media is
they wanted to take
snippets of the film
and
share it just to make the point and the
reviewers kept saying the same thing i
think i saw
10 or 15 reviews they all said the same
thing i can't even show some of the
material on this film because it would
be illegal for me to share it and then i
thought
well wait i you know my constituents
can't share images from this film
because it's so
sexually explicit and uh um
in its depiction of these 11 and 12 year
old girls
so if you can't share the stuff on
social media you can't share it on
youtube you can't share it on vimeo you
can't share it on any of the video
hosting sites
if you can't do that as a private
citizen how come netflix can
it would be illegal for you to share the
material um it's a movie that was made
in france and i understand that the
europeans have very different standards
um and are are
quite willing to push the limits of of
what you can show um
uh but
a number of attorneys looked at this
this film um some of them watched the
entire thing a number of reviewers said
that they couldn't finish watching the
film they watched about 20 or 30 minutes
of it they said this is this is gastly
uh just a quick summary of some of the
things shown in there um
underage girl exposes her breast in a
sexually explicit manner
um 11 and 12 year old girls twerking
grinding
humping the ground uh
according to this 650 girl sent in
twerking videos
uh one of the producers i guess was
convicted already before making the
movie of some
type of sex offense and he was still
allowed to participate making the movie
and it was sex offense against children
provocative wet t-shirt dance
i won't go into that one
barobotics are shown in a scene
one scene which i did not see
is described as mimicking hardcore
pornography
another one is a dance scene where these
girls are sexually twerking to escape
two guards and one of them has is the
movie makes it obvious that the guy is
some type of pedophile
um
for people who measure the time seven
and a half minutes of close-ups of the
crotch but in breast areas of these
girls
there's one extreme zoom in after
another and not just that they zoom in
but that they stay zoomed in
um
uh imdb put this in
the category sex and nudity
and
um
oh disclaimer right after i submitted
this i didn't do some background
research on netflix
um through open secrets and they did
give six and a half million dollars to
democrat campaigns last cycle if that
matters to anyone hope it doesn't
but right after i put this in
on
23rd of september 2020 netflix was
indicted by a grand jury in tyler county
texas on a charge that it quote depicts
the ludix exhibition of the genitals or
pubic area of a clothed or partially
clothed child who was younger than 18
years of age
so
this is one of those cases where
exhibition of this movie
probably violates state law it certainly
violates federal laws
and
um
it's
you know court court presidents
change the law change the way we
interpret the law change the way we see
the law they're based on crimes that are
actually committed and i think the new
area
um
on obscenity law
that would come out of this case if this
were actually prosecuted by the
department of justice
is is this question which is what all
the reviewers kept asking
was this scene really necessary was this
shot really necessary did they really
need seven and a half minutes of
close-ups on their shorts areas
um
every reviewer is asking that same but
almost every reviewer's asked the same
question and people are asking me do
they really need to show this image and
that image and this scene
and the
partial nudity by underage girls over
and over again
i understand the point that the film is
trying to make
um i agree that
conservative parents
are
certainly having a difficult time in
today's society
trying to instill values into their kids
when their kids are being constantly
bombarded with sexualized image imagery
i understand that message
and i actually agree with that message
however
there
the film itself
is so
brazenly
[Music]
and so clearly illegal it is so
it it's so openly and repeatedly
violates the spirit
of the law
that um
you know they could have edited the film
they could have cut out most of the
scenes or bettered it yet not shot most
of those scenes shooting the scenes
themselves would be illegal if it were
done in the united states
um
and they could have used 18 year old
actresses they could have pointed the
camera at the ground they could have
implied a number of things everyone just
kept calling this movie pedobate or that
it's that it's marketed to people who
want to see
sexualized images of 11 and 12 year old
girls i think that it's
it's certainly inappropriate a handful
of people on social media said well it's
a free speech issue
but
it wouldn't be a free speech issue if we
had someone
else who'd already been a convicted sex
offender
making yet another video like this
just let's say for his own entertainment
or
to abuse kids to just take a movie like
that
and then add on
that they're putting it out in front of
millions and millions of viewers there
are several online petitions that have
gathered i think two to three million
signatures there's a
really big boycott of netflix they saw a
dramatic drop off in their their
membership there's a lot of people angry
and i put this up as a kind of informal
hole
and just about everyone said you know
take it down
the corporation should be investigated
um this is
this is approaches a lot of people
wanted to see the executives in
jail and people just keep asking that
same question why did they do this why
did they meet this this is being
described as something akin to
um
saying it's wrong to murder somebody
so therefore we're just we're going to
go out and make a movie actually
murdering somebody and then sending the
message this is bad everybody knows
that
well i guess 97 of people know that um
sexually explicit material
um
of very very young girls who
uh don't have any life experience yet
um
you know i i couldn't even describe some
of the some of the scenes in here
um
i i wouldn't describe some of the scenes
in this movie even in this in this room
it's so brazenly illegal it's so
brazenly long what they did
that it's almost like these
federal laws and some of our state laws
on sexually explicit material with
minors if they were to try to make this
movie in new hampshire
they probably would have been shut down
even when they had the
you know 650
girls as young as nine years old sending
in material of working and they watched
hundreds and hundreds of hours of girls
doing this and some of them
have you know prior convictions and i
just think
some things kind of walk the line and
then other things are just
way way
way over this was
it's wrong it was illegal and i think
that we need to send a message that
this is not what should be put on here
okay
thank you uh representative
do i have any uh questions
are there any questions at all uh
representative market uh thank you
representative for for being here uh
just a question uh i'm not i understand
not a fan of it sounds terrible but do
you think that the
this type of uh resolution uh raising
awareness about the show you have any
concern that this type of thing
will uh make more people aware of it
than otherwise that has it ever been a
concern or something you thought of
um
is this a concern that more people
become aware of the movie uh
yeah it was a concern when i drafted
this i was looking for a different
approach maybe if i just wrote if i just
write a letter to the department of
justice and do this on down below
but
um i think that what the goal is
for me is to get more and more people to
boycott netflix
get more people to cancel and i think
that people have to see this is what
netflix is doing this is the string of
movies that hollywood is making that i
mentioned in the resolution um this is
part of a pattern of putting out
sexually explicit material was trying to
increasingly sexualize
not just teenagers now they're going to
preaching
okay
have you heard the expression banned in
boston ever
and the reason i ask that is because
historically there have been cases where
books have been banned
and books would want to be banned in
boston because that would
help them to sell more books so that's
that's my concern my question is this
type of activity making more people
aware of it and maybe increasing the
viewership of this series uh that was
just so bad in boston doesn't ring the
bell
uh i'm from seattle and we have other
expressions of kind of me in the scene
all right all right thank you i i get
what you're you're going at i think
um
[Music]
i just have a question about um
federal authority over these types of
things um
netflix
and i'm saying this night asking this
question naively netflix is a
cable-based
uh company
and for example the fcc doesn't that
only have authority over things that go
through the air
ergo um
wouldn't uh for example the fcc not
carry weight
over this um i might have a follow-up
question but go ahead
um
i think that things sent over the
internet
i don't know the fcc's charter but i i
know that the fcc's jurisdiction is
triggered
if things go over the airwaves like
through wi-fi and whatnot and
the jurisdiction that i'm i'm going
after is under the department of justice
okay follow-up
no that answers my question thank you
mr chair thank you
okay uh is there anything else
i represent i got a couple questions for
you on this here
uh of course i've never seen this here
but on like i my wife has a comp for
netflix and we watch a lot of movies
um
you know in those movies there's some
type of nudity like on for instant rain
the viking news and all that and the
things that i've been watching about the
historical data on uh
the uh attacks between frank spain and
italy and all that stuff and many years
ago the 1300s
my concern is there's nudity in those
there now these are children
and there's also in those movies but
it's cable
that people paid for
is there a lot laws there or i mean how
do they do this here
with those uh with young 13 15 year olds
that got married back then in their
movies
um they're training it whether they are
or not i don't know
it's generally done if it does violate
federal law does violate 18 usc 2251
usually the department of justice opens
up a case
um on requesting people who have
evidence and the fbi does the actual
investigation and then the federal
prosecutor takes it to federal court
think of it like somebody
going online and trying to find the same
material but not in a moving format
that's sold but in some type of uh child
pornography or something that's explicit
material on 11 and 4 it would be
prosecuted in the same way except that
you now have corporation netflix
involved
will you bring to tell pornography like
i said is there
children nudity in this thing in its
film
there's uh uh partial nudity define
partial news what is there is one
image where
uh
probably underage girl
exposes her bare breast intentionally
obviously the director is older to do
that for that scene
there's another one where a girl's
pants are pulled down so that her bear
buttocks are shown
i mean obviously at some point a jury of
your
peers has to look at the material and
see and
you know kind of decide is this
is it necessary or is this just
the reason i asked this here is i had a
mother
asked me
you know about this here that her
daughter does cheerleading
and in some of those cheerleading moves
are very seductive or the way they dress
and everything else
and is that in line with this cutie
stuff
well what's it called the movie here
cuties yeah well
i when i was in high school i also saw
the the girls at a certain age 16 or 17
would sometimes you know push the
boundaries
but but that was like
you know two seconds of twerking or
something this is like seven and a half
minutes of pumping and grinding the
camera and
pumping the ground and
just
just i mean even trying to remember
little snippets of these seeds is just
like
if
it's not that they push the limits like
high school cheerleaders it's
they've gone
so far over so completely far over it's
so
it's so undeniably illegal it so
violates the spirit of the law that
they're just
it's not even the same it's true
my last question uh for you and i'll go
to the representative another question
is that uh i aren't there already laws
that are already out there that define
nudity and define pornography and define
child
pornography that are already in place i
mean are we looking for them
in this here which are the way i read it
they tell them
comply with the law or we interpreted
that we're doing something wrong
that
maybe they're not seeing what we're
seeing to hear a new answer
well again well it's a
federal law that the the house
resolutions addresses um we
could have also gone the uh
the the state statute we also have um
criminal codes that are also felony
provisions
um for
airing this material in the state
um
my concern there is that in general
state laws they usually just go after
people after watching this at home
naively thinking that it's just a kid's
dance group
and now instead of netflix which is kind
of surprising people very over the top
sexualized material now you're putting
just ordinary viewers in jeopardy of
liberal prison time just for instantly
watching the movie that they think
you know it can't get bad and then it
just works it can't get worse than this
and it gets much it can't get through
that it gets much
so
the state law part i didn't get into
because my concern was
that the attorney general's office might
be you know might be at risk of real
prison time real prosecution you know
that that wasn't the intent of the law
just watching tv just watching
commercial tv
you don't think that when you turn on
the tv you're gonna see
you know
riverline child overnight
you expect to see
material that is lawful
material that might push the limits with
high school cheerleaders or something
like that it doesn't you know
but uh you know sexualized material with
11 year olds you don't expect to see it
and it's just kind of
a real surprise
okay one last question i thought that
was going to be the end whereas all
these like senators congressmen that you
got in here that made comments
uh are they all not the police the fire
uh what not fire but the police
secretary fbi are they all not doing
their job
on banning this here the fcc
on
why is it still playing i mean are they
not doing their job and getting it off
the air because it's all pornography uh
the movie is still on here but the
uh u.s attorney general is
a political appointee appointed by the
president
and
sometimes hollywood gets away with stuff
that private citizens could never get
away with because they're big political
companies uh i mean saw the weinstein
case i'm not going to go into that that
that was one of the biggest political
donors and stuff weinstein was getting
away with was just
you know we're seeing this
um
courts in their criminal courts and of
course we have
you know federal state county and local
um
to pursue something in the civil court
you have to have a positive action
sometimes that's common law sometimes we
come up with that legislature but i
think that the cause of action would
come from
uh the parents of these girls
uh
who would be
harmed and they would have i believe
they would just have a right under the
federal the sorry the french courts not
the federal courts uh what i'm looking
at is just the violations of 18 usc
uh 2251 and 2252 two federal laws and
those are those are criminal laws and
they're felony low
violations
thank you all right thank you um
see are they ready okay are there any
other questions uh for anyone here
or anyone on the uh
okay um thank you very much
representative davidson
now is there anyone else out there that
has not wanted to have not signed up to
watch to speak
please raise your hand
okay so you know hands are raised uh we
have
zero support and the two people that
signed into a pose i'm gonna close the
hearing
i am gonna go into executive
session on open up on hr7
and i call on
uh representative shares uh to
make a motion
i uh
i'm wondering if uh the staff um mr
greenland can uh put the amendment up
that's great to do it right here
if this works i think i got it off
everyone there it is
you did a good job
okay i have the amendment up there for
everyone to see and i mean
let me go to here
and uh representative loomis you wanted
to make a second did i hear you say that
oh yes absolutely okay we have a second
from representative
uh representative body you can go ahead
and speak to your amendment please yeah
so um the amendment essentially if you
go to uh the first club the last
paragraph line is uh 30 and 31 of take
one of the original piece of legislation
you'll notice that basically what this
changes in the ultimate uh purpose is to
change the very clock that the house
clerk saying honking the best revolution
to netflix to remove this bill from
distribution
that i would rather instead say that the
new hampshire house represents fear by
condemning the film's duties an epic
decision to release and promote the film
and the reason for this is because no
duke brought up a statement
has been taken by the federal government
against the actions of the filmmakers or
netflix and i don't find our legislature
to be like lawyers or judges where we
can just assume
time has been committed right we believe
in due process in our legislature right
we're all constitutional conservatives
down at least you know within our
so
i think we need to take um we need to
just change this wording so that it's
more forthright
and knowing that you know the purpose of
this is to condemn the movie and to
condemn netflix profiting off such a um
such inappropriate contract
and to ensure that we also still tell
the doj to investigate this so that if
they have committed a crime right then
they can have the full force of the
on broadcast so that's the purpose of
the amendment and i hope that the
representatives from both parties are
considerate and vote
thank you all right thank you uh do i
have anyone else i want to speak uh for
against the amendment
you don't see it i don't see anyone on
here
who's waving put your hand up so we
could tell because i can't see way back
okay
representative welcome
thank you mr chair i i just want to say
i don't know if anyone else agrees with
me but uh and i not that i want to see
this thing uh but
that it's hard for me to vote one way or
the other without
seeing it and i'm just putting this idea
out there that
if we're gonna vote on this then maybe
we should
first see it
because as the supreme court justice who
said you know it when you see it i
i feel like it's uh
i just don't know until i until i see it
i you know some i can understand what
you're saying here and you know how you
want to vote that's up to you uh but
this bill has been up there for now
about a week or two you would definitely
have the opportunity to do it me i had
no interest in watching not just a
freedom of speech guys and know that we
there's a fine line we got to be careful
on
and i respect the ones that did their
decisions uh the ones that did watch it
but
right representatives oh that's i'll
just be all you know that's the
direction because we're in the gateway
yes
so um
so the question is more about the
overall hr and right now the question
that we've moved is on the amendment
so i think this kind of addresses some
of your concerns on representative
welcoming that we're not saying that any
crime has been committing
and you know requesting that netflix
take it down that currently we're
condemning and then we're asking for an
investigation to see if this is speech
that goes against fdp guidelines and
that goes against specific federal
statutes and i think you know what
you're kind of bringing up is a debate
that we'll be having after we vote on
this event and if that makes any sense
okay do we have any other uh any
questions or
anything else everyone had
who was
for okay on
if there's nobody else right okay
without further delay then i'm gonna
move to a uh well i can't do a show
again so i gotta take a roll call
uh
okay why don't we go to the clerk and
call for roll call it's kind of tough
you haven't and then and now it's the
roll call is on an otpa
no it's only uh
on the amendment yeah okay i'm asking uh
we're getting
the pass on amendment number
uh
we will also
can you see if there's a copy of this
amendment over there for the file
for the court
[Music]
okay we can just do it anyways but in
this case
okay so this is this is for our past on
amendment to hr 7.
vice chairman moffat hi
david lundgren yes
phyllis
cat sports yes
yes
matthew will help you yes
benny
yes
who is
[Music]
yes
do we miss anybody
okay uh we have a motion on the floor do
we have a second uh representative
yes sir i
suck at that okay we have a second and
uh representative uh as ought to pass
his amendment to close your eyes
so um i just like to thank uh
representative for providing a number of
this information about qb and kind of
why i think we should pass this because
uh movie communities doesn't only
contain uh you know it contains not only
extremely inappropriate content for
content that should not be considered
permissible in our society it's quite
flexibly illegal from underage nudity to
an eleven-year-old dancing in a wet
t-shirt as well as seven minutes of a
close-up on
11 and 12 year old girls
grinding this is not content that the
federal communications commission should
allow
in our country it's not stuff that we
would see on a daily table it's not
stuff that we should even allow online
for on netflix even if someone correctly
stays
senator ted cruz and senator tom cotton
have also written to the department of
justice noting that the material appears
to violate 18 u.s code 2 200 251 and
watching or even sharing images from the
film we should always condemn the
sexualizing of children and profiting
from such a great
thank you
do i have anyone else that wants to uh
speak out on uh uh for or against
anything on this
okay so you know uh we have
we have someone mr chairman
uh
okay go ahead and uh who am i who's
talking to speak
representative massimilia
uh go inside my representative max
miller the floor is yours
thank you mr chair mr chair do you
happen to have a copy
of the original
hr that you could put up in the screen
and enlarge because i lost my copy and i
only have the amendment to compare it to
um no i i don't
and the reason why i don't you could do
the same thing i would have to do right
now
is go into the calendar
and you can bring it up there go into
our committee and look under h.r um
uh yeah we couldn't do that but what i'm
trying to say is if the bill did
normally we don't we all get the bills
yeah and people
look in front of us
and bring it up if that's what you
wanted right
because she's pretty talented knowing
that representative did their ranking
number
now when it comes to i.t not at all
again
no i'm not talented when it comes to
anything technological
okay
if you would like i do have the the
original bill up in front of me i can um
share my screen if you would like
and brad can you enlarge that please
when you do
and let me know when it's up
okay
all right this should be up now
uh can you enlarge it please
it's already
okay
so it don't it's going
[Music]
i have my glasses on and i still can't
see it if you'd like representative
massimo i can also email this to you why
don't you do that that would be great if
people don't mind
so what's what's happening right now
because we're ready to move forward
i know
can i speak mr chairman
thank you mr chairman i just want to uh
i guess speak out loud or think out loud
for a second i don't think
anyone here is uh in favor of
the descriptions that representative
abramson gave to describe this movie but
i'm also concerned as
you mr chairman alluded to the first
amendment implications
i'm not sure
that
it's appropriate for this house
to be
essentially calling for the censorship
of something
which
is known to the department of justice
and has apparently been deemed not
illegal
despite attorney and mr abramson's
remarks that it's clearly and obviously
illegal
and especially given that it appears
that none of the members of the
committee have actually watched the
movie
i don't think that members of the house
should necessarily be
censoring things or calling for
censorship of things sight unseen
even if they're not you know things that
we like or things that may be
frankly horrifying
so what i'd like to know is if there's
any other members of the committee
especially on
your side of the aisle mr chairman that
have any support for the idea of voting
down this
motion and proposing a motion to retain
this bill so i don't think it's simply
appropriate for us to be voting on
something sight unseen with the
implications that such a vote has
well thank you uh
[Music]
representative uh
i'll address that real quick and i
definitely see you know the gentleman's
concern involved thank you mr speaker i
mean i definitely see the gentleman
representative
but i think um as the chairman
previously alluded to we did have two
weeks to view or do research on this and
it has been
it's not to force them off the air and
it's to request that the federal
government we're just requesting federal
government look into the tf2 laws have
been violated but an apparently you know
we have the fcc that's allowed to repeat
what kinds of things go on here whether
it's on netflix or in our table so this
is just requesting that they double
check into this after we condemn the
kind of things that we've heard about
and we've heard about their constituents
have problems with a concern so i
definitely see your reservations but
i don't think we're jumping the gun
per se
on this i think there's a lot of for me
that's what they're about
to watch
thank you uh representative you took the
words right out of the remote because i
did not feel like you watch it but i did
research the uh information that was out
there on it we all have plenty of time
and i want to thank each and every one
of my committee members here because
when we caught this you all did your
homework on it came up with amendment
and everything else so we're ready to
vote we cannot take others by the end
and show them how to research or how to
look and do things prior to a community
hearing uh but i want to thank the
representative uh i don't know if he's
probably a freshman and it could be a
lesson learned
to do homework prior to looking there
like we've done here and everyone that
came in with their regular lock but
anyways i want to move forward if
there's anyone else that wants to speak
up i'm ready to go to a vote yes uh
representative lane can you take it off
can you please
that's i mean laughton thank you
yes this is stacy um
thank you mr chairman um
i feel like
this is uh
you know basically confirming what is
already
you know illegal and uh
you know though i'm a democrat
um
i'm
going to be supporting this because
you know it's already illegal
to have
any performers under the age of 18
and i feel like you know
we shouldn't be afraid to vote one way
or the other and i'm sorry i'm going to
support it
thank you representative laughlin um
i mean there's a lot of things that come
forward we agree with this opinion
thank you mr chair i want to echo
representative piedra's concerns i had
the same concerns
uh which is why
one of the reasons why an amendment came
forth
and again this is just a resolution like
the chairman and like i think most of
you i'm a very big first amendment
supporter and i expressed concern about
a slippery slope
uh the amendment addresses my concern
and i can i can support this as amended
so anyway i deal with
uh
for example gandra said and uh share
sentiments but but the amendment uh
sense defies my concerns this
again it's just a resolution
uh
we'll point out as well
thank you
is there anyone else are on there before
we go to a vote
stated none i'm going to ask the clerk
to vote
ought to pass
uh hr7 arthur pass has uh amended
with eventual
yes
yes i think you called on me
yes i did
um
yes
we're having trouble hearing you
is it is it catherine harvey are you
taking
yes i'm here i'm sorry i didn't you're
very garbled i did not hear my name but
i vote yes thank you
are you replacing i'm sorry to ask again
are you sitting for
matt wilhelm today
no he said no she's sitting for willis
griffin
that's what i thought okay
i don't have the pawns
on he's not saying
he's
yes cat representative catherine harvey
voted yes and i am not subbing for matt
wilhelm i'm celeb uh substituting for
griffin
yes okay i do have that thank you so
much representative harvey i'm still
looking for matthew wilhelm
matthew wilhelm votes yes
thank you
yes marie logan
no
okay
lawrence
yes
okay
now the vote is 19 to 2 will there be a
minority report
no
no no minority report
okay
foreign
on our resolution city and i'm going to
welcome back representative edwardson
always here to help
chairman baldur sarah
i might have to stay home with my
pajamas on the next one
okay please don't
thank you
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee
representative maxi crimson from hampton
hampton falls
introducing my last bill for the day
which is hr house resolution eight
requesting an investigation into whether
or not
the over prescription of opioids
benzodiazepines and exposure to chemical
agents
has contributed to suicide by veterans i
this is my
um introducing this again last year i
asked legislative services
to do this as a house resolution somehow
it came back as a house concurrent
resolution
um
and i there was no way after the fact
without changing the the rules so
this
passed unanimously through this
committee then it went encountered
passed unanimously through the house
um and
because of the coronavirus lockdown this
this bill ended up getting killed so
just
uh oh i'm sorry
it got killed based on uh some of the
senate rules but here i'm redoing it as
a house resolution correctly um
representative uh
binford and greeson and ankerberg and i
worked on this bill last year i worked
with uh representative albsaro to to get
this
correct the the the source of the
problem is that we've noticed over the
years that there's been a much higher
suicide rate among armed service
veterans
than amongst the general public and at
some points it's been as high as twice
as high
and we don't know what all the reasons
are that are contributing to that um we
have seen it decline uh from 22 a day
down to 21 a day last year we don't have
2020s numbers in but they're expecting
the numbers to go up again
and
there
have been so many issues have been
brought up over the years by veterans
what they think is contributing to
these these problems
we found out
after noticing that that non-veterans
in the private sector who had been
prescribed opioids and benzodiazepines
at the same time each had a slightly
higher
suicide risk and higher rates of
depression if they were used but if they
were used together at the same time they
had dramatically higher rates
of suicide okay
there have been several other issues
brought up
um i missed the ptsd issue which i
thought should have been obvious people
have been exposed
to
stress
combat and seeing
close friends die in front of them
and subject to torture when they come
back they have a very very difficult
time
coming back from combat and coming back
from very long deployments
uh trying to adjust
some are not able to adjust
and they go from a kind of type a
warrior mentality they come back and
they have to just just be uh
workers
for nine to five
a number of veterans have posted
and said that they have uh
veterans often have a difficult time
they're the rescuers they have a
difficult time asking for help
one's responding to help on that that
also came up in uh last year's bill
emergency under suicide which also faced
very high
rate of uh
they face a high suicide rate also
um this one the amendment that i i'm
asking members to support is sponsored
by representative binford
and it adds a long list of other
chemicals that are known to have
psychoactive effects and also adds
ptsd
and exposure to
certain vaccines
some of the chemicals
we think might be associated with high
rates of depression
um
and uh and other neurological problems
chemical problems
um they can develop in the brain and can
and
can develop over time
i can't even pronounce some of the
chemicals that our military guys are
exposed to but i'll i'll give you a
quick story when i
left army rotc i went back home after i
left college
i wasn't able to continue with rotc and
i remember specifically pushing the
lawnmower i was i think 19 or 20 years
old i was pushing the lawnmower and
thinking and thinking and thinking if i
wanted to enlist
as an enlisted man i was going to go
become an officer in the army
and i remember thinking of something
that george washington said he said that
our ability to recruit soldiers for our
future wars depends on how we treat
the veterans of our our past wars
and i remember at that time as a young
man thinking whether or not i would go
in
and remembering all the stories from the
prior service guys from rotc all the
things that they'd said that they'd been
through
in the military the chemicals that
they'd been exposed to
and
what they had been exposed to
through the va and the va hospitals and
dealing with the department of defense
and bureaucracy
and the medical problems that they dealt
with
and at the time that was my reason for
not
going in and enlisting and re-enlisting
going from rotc to enlistment
and i thought
uh
you know when i was out on a merchant
ship we were going into war zones as i
was telling uh uh chairman balbosaro
we had all these military guys and we
were bringing military personnel to the
middle east and uh to into these
theaters of operation and thinking
you know we're in a hazardous zone now
but a lot of these guys are not going to
come back and some of them didn't come
back some of them died over there
and
it
it becomes impossible for us
as a society
to
to recruit these guys
um to serve
if we're not going to do everything we
possibly can now after the fact for our
armed service veterans there's the
reason that i got back into
legislative stuff i dropped out of
politics some years ago the reason i got
back into it is because of measures like
this because of issues like i wanted to
help take care of our armed service
veterans
they put forth so much they've risked so
much and they've sacrificed so much from
their family lives their personal lives
and their financial lives they've given
up so much
and we need to ask each generation as
they come along when they're you know
pushing the lawnmower and they're facing
that decision do they just go right back
to the private sector
do they uh do they go in and serve in
uniform and i think it
there there's only a little bit that we
can do
at the legislators but i'm gonna do
everything that i can
and stuff i am happy to reintroduce this
house resolution and i hope that the i
hope the department of veterans affairs
and i hope that congress will hold
hearings and look into all of these
possible contributors to veteran
suicides so we're still at 21 21 veteran
suicides per day we don't have last
year's figures in yet but
i i can't imagine that
it's going to be good news
thank you
you realize that since marks at 75
has been a 75 increase
the veterans that i've had the
opportunity to
continue to tell me
when they were in
uh i've had that discussion with
secretary of the va to washington
you're making steps to do this to reduce
it
however um
if the
vet that goes into the hospital or
pain relief
how do i say it
doesn't has it have his own sense of
honor
he takes those pills and immediately
you become addicted within five days so
bill there a question there somewhere
i'm sorry
anyway um
thank you
yes i would agree with that in fact i
hope that this investigation finds
christianity
um opioids and benzodiazepines in
general
uh
by the way
according to a couple veterans i talked
to is that there were cuts and
benefits va services for counseling and
so sometimes if they didn't have enough
counselors and therapists that they
would just kind of medicate the problem
right and that and that's just
too much
representative i've been in the va since
three places that operate in a tent
um they're too hot
heart attacks had cancer and stomach and
you know i mean whatever but the bottom
line is i used to be given oxycodone
like candy and i would use the
prescriptions all the time
uh throughout the va but i can tell you
throughout the years that somebody who
other just thoughts about it uses the
system
the being is
so much better
okay on this here on uh they're throwing
out these bills they're putting through
paying clinics everything else so i mean
but years ago representative longwood
100 right it was like candy they were
given to you sometimes i would get them
in the mail you know i mean and then
smash them and stuff and then sometimes
somebody would steal them
okay so you know but like i said the va
is getting done many of these studies
are being done
um through the va because i like i said
i'm i use them constantly
but the thing what i liked about here
with coming forward was representative
london's comments about things that
that's been complaining
in this chiropractor and certain
different other type of specialty
you know things here which is gonna make
us so much better why we're all happy
about it so
um
i just wanna and we you remember last
time we did pass your momentum
resolution and that's why i'm hoping
we'll assume we're going to go to a boat
to this here so and i'll leave it to it
because i have questions
you know what else i bought on the uh
i'm not here to miss anybody you have
any questions
okay
i don't have anyone that signed up to
speak for or against us here is there
anyone out there that else has signed up
that wants to speak for or against
seeing none
okay i'm going to close the mirror 198
r8 and i'm going to open up the
independence
i know
the executive session
for hr8 and i am going to go to
uh give me a second here so i can catch
up with this one
okay
yes sir i have an amendment for hr eight
uh and what your amendment uh that
you're talking about amendment hr eight
is one second i'm gonna put it up for
excluding that 20 21
21 0 0 9 7 8.
um
right
you made the motion out the back door
and who was seconded
representative skip did i hear you say a
second wrong second again okay i have a
second right
okay
pass on amendment
uh
zero zero nine seven eight
here
uh skip rollins uh second
really
doesn't have to be but we do it anyways
you want to speak to your amendment
yes this amendment
basically just continues to encourage
the congress united states department of
defense and veterans affairs to
investigate
the effects of opioids
and
all the other uh things in here that i'm
not going to try and pronounce
i get a little tongue tied sometimes
as well as adds to it
um
conditions for alternative care methods
for records so they do not have to
go the route of opioids or other
questionable um prescriptions
it's pretty straightforward pretty
simple and i feel it fits very well with
the initial house resolution hate
submitted by
representative abramson thank you uh
representative i think i think it's a
great amendment but uh do we have anyone
else that's willing to
step up you said he ends up missing
seeing that we have nobody
step it up this week
then i will um ask the clerk to take a
vote on hr eight amendment uh number
zero zero nine seven eight
and partner pass
vice chairman of it
yes
[Music]
myself yes david
yes yes
yes okay
uh do you know harley yes
don't love
yes
matthew wilhelm
amanda
yes
tony lebranch
yes oh and uh chairman balthasar yes
yes
okay
uh
representative i hear you're saying you
want to make a motion about the past
yes i would like to make the most of it
okay
we have a motion out to pass as amended
with eight zero zero nine seven eight
but hr8 and would you like to speak your
motion
just simple
thank you anyone else uh do i have
anyone on the
oklahoma street
uh let's go to our uh vote uh alaska
clerk to take a vote
which was on hr8 ought to pass as
amended
with amendment zero zero nine seven each
question first chairman
[Music]
yes
david lundgren yes
phillips yes yes
yes
tina hurley yes john levitt yes
israel
yes
estabia boris
william
matthew wilhelm yes
yes
i can't hear
yeah
okay thank you sorry about that even
here um amanda tall
yes
toilet branch
i didn't hear my name called catherine
harvey votes yes
i did call your name catherine sorry
about that
okay
okay so that's uh the vote is 21 to
nothing yeah um and he is putting this
on the consent down
here we know
resolution number nine
on support and principle
and i will let me see who's the spencer
representative folsom
okay uh replacing uh any of the coast
boxes on
uh
um
hr9 and we're going to open it up uh in
accordance with 315 thank you to my
representative for kitchener because i'm
trying to move things along
representative
so we're we are right now on break until
3 15.
uh well actually we're not on break
we're not on break sorry about that sit
down
don't go nowhere let me gather my papers
please
i need written
i'll give you a second here to get
together on hb112
just keep in mind my representatives
here the the more we get today though
maybe we won't have to come back to a
second day
okay then i won't have to pick on
representative messenger if it's not
coming in
yo we'll go back to be a buddy
i'm sure you can find other things to
pick on me about
remember see what they don't all know is
you came to my wedding you're probably
gonna come to florida hang out with me
right
you don't have to acknowledge that smile
if you'll come out and visit
all right i want to um open up the exec
session on house bill on
uh 112.
and i'm just giving you one second here
uh representative uh
i'm going to close the uh executive
session on
hb
112. and we're going to recess till 3
15.
we're going into recess until uh
3 15 that's our next hearing
is there any other bills that we can
exact before then
like h117 or 114 you're executing any
other bill
um we're done on that bill so we'll be
doing the uh hearings the last bill is
one less hearing
okay
that's what you wanted right
well i was just thinking if we've got
time and we've got um
hb112 well 114 and 117
could we do them since we've had the
hearings one of my um representatives um
republicans uh doctor got called out he
had to leave
anymore
you know for them that's why he's pretty
exact so i
out of respect uh
[Music]
because he's been here all day and they
got called out so
oh okay so in other words we would have
exact them but he left so we're not
doing it is that correct normally i
would say how the hell are you going to
go you got to go but because he's a
doctor
out of respect for him
okay
i mean it's like if you had to go i'd
say right no big deal
well that system tried still my role
[Music]
yeah it was called in my house when i
left this morning
yeah we've got about six inches and
right now it's 14 degrees
we're close to heat wave status
i'm going back to florida tuesday for a
week
so um al what time are we reconvening
uh 3 15.
okay thank you
the person
is
uh we do not we have representative fred
you said uh
okay out of respect for representative
potion who is not there
uh
does have
um
[Music]
uh uh i'll i'll introduce it sir
chairman
um hr 9 is
a bill basically that supports the
principles of federalism
as as seen as
the commitment of new hampshire for all
citizens unalienable rights and all
constitutional civic authority for the
state of new hampshire
do i have anyone else that
wants to speak on this guild at all
[Music]
this is something that we've seen before
and it's important uh
you know in the past that you know
you know which is basically to build uh
would be the resolution that connects
your sports principles of federalism
federalism as a system of government
two levels of government control the
same territory with both the national
subdivisions have the power to make laws
that have uh autonomy for one another
uh pretty good resolution that they
can't go anywhere
i don't know because either mine uh
anyone that's been around two or three
or four more during some of my weight
know that the democrats and republicans
in the senate
don't take up a lot of resolutions and
they need at least five six five
senators
to support it for coming forward
so keep that in mind on these here
uh
yeah there's an appointment free um is
this a house resolution or a house
this is a house resolution
it looks good
it'll only be the house position will
not be the center position
yeah so all we're doing is uh
democrats republicans have leave chris
here
[Music]
i just did i lost you for a minute i
lost the whole meeting for a minute
let me ask you some are you on board
with this here
um i
i'm not sure i think some maybe and some
may not be
okay
and there is a reason why i mean
i'm missing a couple uh
reps that had it going
i'll put this off until uh i just wanted
to check with you and see what you want
well thank you thank you i appreciate
that
what i'll do is i'll put this off to
exec on uh february 12th 12.
that sounds good
anyone else have anything to add on this
here i'll put up all the likes for the
uh
yeah
yeah did anyone else have anything
before i close this hearing on hr9
okay i'm going to close it's on nine
all right so everyone's information uh
february 12th
nine o'clock
we're going to be injecting the build uh
what we have left is by people x7
uh so for planning purposes
we should be able to be do it we'll do
it in the morning and hopefully within
two hours or so we'll be done
okay so that way if you have any plans
or work or whatever that afternoon
you'll be able to do that
uh there's an important questions for me
al what was the date on that
february 12th
12th
it's a friday
nine o'clock in the morning
okay
thank you
okay and um and then we will be finished
and then wait for any senate bills to
come over
um
everybody's happy
uh for the freshmen uh did we do all
right
you know so make it easy so everyone
could understand so because
you know what he republican democrat
don't make a difference you've been
elected to do the people's business
thank you to everyone here
and nobody has anything else to add i
will sign off
thank you all yes sir uh lawrence did
you have something
oh okay
all right you all have a good day then
we'll see you